Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Moin.
Oh, ein bisschen leiser machen gerade.
Und habt ihr gut geschlafen, Chat?
Oder schlaft ihr noch?
Gerade dabei sind, ich sehe hier gerade meine Garmin-Uhr rumliegen.
Ich muss mal gucken,
was heute dran ist.
Run.
Training.
Workouts.
Okay, ich hab heute
zur Auswahl
Also ich hab heute zur Auswahl
Ich variier das immer ein bisschen, weil
es gibt, also
Also die Garmin App generiert quasi anhand der aktuellen Werte, die man so hat, einen Trainingsplan für die Woche.
Der ist eigentlich auch ganz nice und abwechslungsreich, aber manchmal widerspricht sich die Garmin App selbst.
Es gibt nämlich so einen Button da drin für Trainingsstatus und das sagt einem dann,
wie man so sein, ob man sein Training optimal verteilt hat, ja, also quasi niedriger Herzfrequenzbereich,
dann ein bisschen angestrengter und dann auch quasi kurze Sprints und so.
Und die sagt mir immer, wenn ich mich an den Garmin Trainingsplan halte, sagt die mir immer, ja, alles fein,
aber ich habe zu wenig kurzfristige, so intensive Belastung.
So, und jetzt bin ich dazu übergegangen, einfach zu gucken, was die Garmin App für die ganze Woche hier suggestet und dann auch ab und zu mal was zu machen, was gar nicht heute dran wäre, sondern morgen.
Also was habe ich denn heute zur Auswahl? Ich habe heute zur Auswahl 42 Minuten, gucken was ich nachher noch mache, 42 Minuten at 630er Pace, also das ist quasi easy 42 Minuten joggen.
Dann hätte ich zur Auswahl VO2 Max Training, das ist auch 42 Minuten und beinhaltet neben 10 Minuten Ein- und Auslaufen, beinhaltet das 4x4 at 5er Pace.
Und dann hätte ich noch zur Auswahl...
...Anerobik-Training.
Das beinhaltet 7x1 Minute...
...at 4,35er-Pace.
Oh, das ist anstrengend. Das war es jetzt schon.
Das wird anstrengend.
Weil 435 ist für mich
Das packe ich in einen Kilometer oder so
Oder vielleicht
Vielleicht auch 2, wenn ich es voll wissen will
Aber dann bin ich im Arsch
Und das 7 mal eine Minute
Ist anstrengend
Ich meine immerhin weniger anstrengend
Als der irgendwie
2 Kilometer, aber
Welche Garmin Uhr verwendest du?
Moment, kann ich dir zeigen
Ich mach grad mal ein bisschen was
Entspannenderes an
Hier muss man immer die Lautstärke so komisch anpassen
Dann hier noch zwei runter
Sonst backt das irgendwie rum, keine Ahnung
Gute Frage
Ich verwende eine Garmin Forerunner
Kann ich dir gleich zeigen
Eine Garmin Forerunner.
Moment, was steht da hinten drauf?
Ich durfte jetzt Mist erzählen.
Weil ich muss mir eine neue kaufen.
Aber das war die alte.
Nur ob ich das auch wirklich richtig gemacht habe.
Zeig mal her.
255S.
Garmin Forerunner 255S.
Die ist aber outdated.
Das ist nicht mehr die aktuellste.
Mittlerweile gibt es glaube ich eine 265 S oder irgendwie sowas.
Also es gibt quasi eine...
Was ist jetzt hier?
Es gibt quasi eine neuere Generation davon.
Aber wenn du Glück hast...
inklusive was inklusive mehrwertsteuer ab 25 euro
25 euro das wäre ultra geschenkt alter das glaube ich nicht dass es die bay oder
oder?
Achso, Versandkosten
frei ab 25 Euro.
Ja, okay.
Kein Wunder.
I need Dan.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das wäre echt
geschenkt.
Ja, kann man die jetzt hier bestellen, oder nicht?
weil da was von Versandkosten frei steht.
Nee, oder? Kann man nicht.
Also, ihr könnt mal gucken.
Vielleicht habt ihr Glück
und findet noch irgendwo...
Ja, das lohnt sich jetzt.
Das lohnt sich jetzt also wirklich.
Also, davon gibt es eine neuere Version auf jeden Fall.
Ich würde mir die alte dann nicht mehr kaufen.
Aber ich bin echt zufrieden mit der Uhr.
Ich bin echt zufrieden mit der Uhr.
Das war damals schon, das war nicht das Super-Einsteiger-Modell.
Das Super-Einsteiger-Modell war damals die 55S oder 55.
Die reicht in der Regel auch, wenn man jetzt nicht so viel Geld ausgeben will.
Das ist so quasi das Nach-dem-Einsteiger-Modell.
Aber es ist noch nicht das mittlere Modell.
Das ist so ein bisschen das advancede Einsteiger-Modell.
Night Twitch, danke schön.
Huge Subscription, Leute. Massive.
Ja.
So, und wir können jetzt gerade mal gucken.
Es interessiert mich auch, was da jetzt das
Folgemodell ist, tatsächlich.
Jetzt gibt es die
265S. Ja, das kann sein.
200...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der Unterschied ist
zwischen S und nicht S.
Ich sag keine Ahnung.
Boah.
Das ist aber auch ordentlich teurer geworden.
Also ich bilde mir ein, ich hab
ich glaub
240 Euro oder so noch bezahlt.
Gut, das war aber da halt auch schon
Auslaufmodell, ne?
Okay, Größe macht
keinen Unterschied preislich.
der ist TDR5-Rammtrenner.
Ja, das wird's sein.
Ach guck mal, davon gibt's
noch nie.
Also ich würde sagen,
Ida wahrscheinlich am ehesten.
Zumindest, ich finde diese
Garmic-Uhren echt nicht verkehrt, weil
die halten auch relativ lang.
Also wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht mit
einer Apple Watch, die wenn du den ganzen Tag
benutzt unbedingt wieder aufladen musst,
die Garmin
Uhren, die halten auch mal, also wenn du es wirklich
drauf anlegst und nicht jeden Tag stundenlang
Aktivitäten aufzeichnest, halten die auch
mal eine Woche.
Deswegen finde ich das echt ganz nice.
Und das Ökosystem von
Garmin, wenn man
denn sich da Vendor-Log
innen möchte, finde ich auch
ganz nice. Also die Garmin,
Die Garmin Connect App ist ganz gut.
Und die anderen Garmin Produkte.
Ich habe halt noch einen Herzfrequenz-Bandsensor, den ich aber so gut wie nicht anziehe, weil die Uhr alleine reicht.
Und halt noch den Fahrradcomputer von Garmin.
Und das geht halt alles, ohne dass man großartige Sachen machen muss, zusammen in die gleiche App.
Und der checkt halt auch, und das finde ich halt ganz gut, was du so halt, wenn du irgendwie Strava oder Runner oder sonst was verwendest, nicht hast.
Wüsste zumindest nicht wie.
Das erkennt halt, wenn du mit dem Fahrradcomputer eine Runde loggst, dann passt das dein Training fürs Rennen den nächsten Tag an.
Und sowas.
Das finde ich halt echt nice bei den Garmin-Dingern.
Ja.
Sieh ich?
Mich?
Du meinst mich?
Jaja.
Warum soll es mich nicht mal geben?
Ja gut, auf YouTube bin ich nicht so präsent.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
Leute, ich habe es euch gar nicht erzählt.
Der Frazier und ich,
wir waren vor,
ich glaube knapp,
zwei oder drei Wochen,
ganz kurz davor,
ein Video zusammen aufzunehmen.
Aber dann hat es den Fabian überkommen
und er hat bei sich auf dem Channel
ein Video aufgenommen.
und seitdem haben wir auch nicht mehr drüber geschrieben,
aber das müssen wir unbedingt machen.
Wäre es nicht
das Beste...
Das stimmt übrigens gar nicht mehr, der hat sich umbenannt.
Der heißt gar nicht mehr so.
Der heißt nicht so.
Der heißt... Ich habe vergessen, wie der Channel heißt.
Faptwitch oder irgendwie sowas.
Zumindest wäre das nicht
ein nices Comeback-Video,
wenn wir
ein Video zusammen aufnehmen würden.
Wobei, Comeback, keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, komplett aufhören mit YouTube werde ich nie,
auch wenn ich 1, 2, 3 Jahre nix mache.
Ja.
Die Dinge sind auch nicht verkehrt.
Aber auf die Frage hin,
ob ich Garmin Connect oder Strava verwende,
ich benutze tatsächlich
nur Garmin Connect.
Ich hatte mal
jetzt vor ein paar Wochen
Runner ausprobiert.
Aber dass die gleich eine Subscription haben wollen, hat mich ein bisschen abgeschreckt.
Aber was ich halt bei der Garmin Connect App ganz gut finde ist, dass wie gesagt, dass da halt alle Aktivitäten reingehen, die man hat.
automatisch, sobald du Garmin-Geräte
veränderst. Finde ich ganz praktisch. Und was ich
auch gut finde ist, weiß ich nicht,
ob Strava sowas kann
und vor allem ohne Abo und sowas.
Ich finde das automatische Trainingsplan
generieren von Garmin nicht schlecht.
Da musst du dir nicht viele Gedanken
machen. Und das richtig Gute
daran ist halt, dadurch,
dass die nicht einfach
so ins Blaue hinein deine Trainingspläne
generieren, sondern
deine aktuellen Werte haben, die wissen halt,
wie schwer du bist, wie schnell du rennst,
welche Herzfrequenz du hast und wenn du es
theoretisch nachts anziehst, sogar
wie gut du geschlafen hast und da können
die halt die Trainingspläne ziemlich gut anpassen für dich.
Deswegen, ich bin
da ziemlich zufrieden mit
der Garmin Connect App.
Und ich bin
ja auch voll
aktiv so jetzt.
Ich gehe
eigentlich jeden Tag
rennen. Ab und zu mache ich mal einen Tag
Recovery oder Pause.
manchmal mache ich einen Tag, wenn ich zu sehr im Schienbein merke, gehe ich eine Runde Inlineskaten.
Ich weiß, Boomer-Sportart, aber mache ich gerne.
Und ich habe mir jetzt, jetzt kommt noch, jetzt kommt noch, mein Fahrrad ist ja immer noch kaputt, ich habe es immer noch nicht repariert.
Übelst fauler Sack.
Ich habe mir eine Brille gekauft, damit ich ein bisschen schwimmen gehen kann.
Das höchste der Gefühle, was ich, da habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock.
Das höchste der Gefühle, was ich machen werde, vielleicht ab und zu mal ein bisschen üben, um das Laufen zu verbessern.
Stört die Uhr nicht beim Schlafen?
Ne, aber ich ziehe die nicht mehr an beim Schlafen.
Ich hatte die eine ganze Weile beim Schlafen an.
Das merkst du eigentlich gar nicht, da bist du dann ein bisschen dran gewöhnt.
Aber, was für mich ein Nachteil ist,
man kontrolliert sich da super krass, wenn man das macht, ja.
Ich ziehe die, ich ziehe die, ähm,
ich ziehe die Uhr auch wirklich nur an,
wenn ich, wenn ich Sport mache, Aktivitäten aufzeichnen.
Ich, ich, ich zeichne den restlichen Tag nichts mehr auf
und ich zeichne auch keinen Schlaf mehr auf,
weil mich stresst dieses Analysieren von,
von, wie ist Ruhepuls, wie war der Schlaf
und, oh, der Schlaf war heute nur bei, bei,
keine Ahnung, 82%, oh, das ist ganz schlecht.
mich stresst das, aber das liegt
bei mir dran,
dass ich eh
sehr stark auf irgendwelche
Gesundheitswerte und so, dass mich das
schnell mal triggert.
Deswegen gebe ich mir den Stress gar nicht
und nehme einfach nur noch Aktivitäten auf
und gut ist.
Aber die stört nicht, die stört nicht.
Ja, Morpheus, ich habe eh kaum
Videos gefunden, die wir gucken können. Vielleicht ist da was
Spannendes dabei. Das Einzige, ich gucke übrigens
Offstream gerne die
Videos von Morpheus.
Das Ding ist, warum die sich für den Stream meistens nicht so eignen ist, nicht wegen dem Inhalt, sondern die sind so lang.
Und ihr wisst, wenn ich Videos gucke, die lang sind, ich brauche mindestens die doppelte Länge von einem Video, wenn ich mir das zusammen angucke mit euch.
Weil ich gefühlt alle 15 Sekunden Pause drücken muss, um meinen Senf dazugeben muss.
Gerade bei Technik-Videos, wo ich auch was zu sagen kann.
Und dann kann ein halbes Stunden Video auf eineinhalb Stunden ausarten.
Und ich glaube, das ist dann auch nicht so spannend.
Achso, das neueste
Fire-Ship haben wir schon eine ganze Weile
nicht mehr geguckt.
Bei Fire-Ship bin ich mir immer nicht
sicher. Hat Fire-Ship
nicht... Ups.
Hat Fire-Ship nicht... Jetzt wollte ich jetzt gucken.
Keine Ahnung.
BMW bringt... Oh Gott, das muss ich
zum Ragen. Bei Fire-Ship bin ich mir
immer nicht ganz sicher, sind die Videos nicht
mittlerweile komplett KI-geleriert.
The safest way to store Bitcoins
was just hacked. Ah, das habe ich gelesen.
As if last year hasn't been
hard enough.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Irgend so ein
Hardware-Wallet-Token-
Gedöns
gab es eine
Schwachstelle
in
der Firmware
dass die gar keine Zugangs
äh nicht Zugangs, dass die
für das Token, für das Passwort
irgendwie gar keine
random
Zahlen nimmt
so richtig random, obwohl es einen Sensor
dran hat, irgendwie für Rauschen, so echtes
random, sondern irgendwie
ein Seed aus der Uhrzeit und es
ganz einfach zu berechnen ist, ja richtig
3D Implementierung, wisst ihr, wisst ihr woran
mich das erinnert, es gab doch mal
Debian Random Meme
Äh, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne
Nice
Gibt es vielleicht hier, wenn ich danach suche?
Genau, das hier
Da gab es nochmal dieses Debian-Random-Meme
Get random number, return 4
Ich habe vorher mal gewürfelt
Die hatten doch vor Jahren
Das ist schon ewig her. Gab es doch mal Patches? Das könnte jetzt sein, dass es nicht stimmt, was ich sage. Also nehmt das her mit einer Portion Skepsis. War das damals nicht sogar einer von der Telekom, der diese Comets gemacht hat damals? Ich erinnere mich noch noch. Das ist schon locker 10 Jahre her.
Da hat irgendeiner Comments gemacht, Sachen auskommentiert, glaube ich, für irgendwelche SSL oder irgendwelche Crypto Debian Packages, sodass diese Randomize Funktion, die sie öfters benutzt haben, quasi anstatt 2 hoch 128 oder so Möglichkeiten, hatte die dann nur 150.000 Möglichkeiten oder sowas.
Das ist schon 10 Jahre oder so her.
Und das ist aufgefallen, weil die auf einmal in irgendwelchen Signaturdatenbanken Kollisionen hatten.
Und ja, eine Kollision könnte ja eventuell mal sein, auch wenn es extrem unwahrscheinlich ist.
Aber die hatten innerhalb von kurzer Zeit mehrere Kollisionen.
Da haben die gesagt, okay, da muss irgendwas mit dem Random Code nicht stimmen.
Das kann statistisch gesehen, ist das unmöglich.
Das ist statistisch genauso unmöglich gewesen, wie es gab doch mal diesen Skandal, Skandal, Internetaufregung, um irgendeinen Minecraft Speedrunner, der seinen Random Generator, weiß nicht, was der genau gemacht hat,
seinen Minecraft
Client
hat er quasi gepatcht
und hat den
Random Generator halt
weniger random gemacht.
So, dass der mehr
Speedruns rauskriegt.
Dream, ja, genau.
Ja, und
Debian
random.
War das die Telekom?
Äh.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, das ist schon ewig her
mit diesem Debian Random.
Zoom it for Mac.
Hau A ab. Oh Gott.
sloppt Microsoft jetzt auch
auf macOS rum. Sehe ich das richtig?
Leute, ich hab
Leute, ich hab ne Theorie. Wenn ich diesen
Titel hier lese.
Ich hab ne Theorie.
Okay, das ist jetzt
Hard Cag Alu, okay?
Cag Alu Time.
Ich glaube,
dass Microsoft
Windows mittlerweile so versloppt hat,
dass der CEO
es nicht mehr benutzen will.
Und er benutzt jetzt einfach intern Mac.
Und deswegen
portieren die jetzt Windows-Software auf Mac,
damit ihr CEO happy ist.
Meint ihr, das könnte sein
oder ist das zu kek, Alu?
Weil ansonsten wüsste ich nicht, warum man
warum man
somit vor Mac
KI portieren sollte.
Hart verrat am Start.
Ja, die haben jetzt ja
letztens ihre
Ausverkauf-Geschichte gehabt.
Keck Anu, aber ich glaube, du hast recht.
Ja, okay.
Könnte schon sein, oder?
Warte mal, ich will mir das Video nicht angucken.
Ich will nur
die Kommentare lesen, okay?
Zeig mal her.
Ja.
Okay. Ja, guck da.
Es gibt in Mac schon... Ja, wer hätte das gedacht?
Es gibt in Mac schon eine Funktion, um
ranzuzoomen. Da wären wir natürlich nicht drauf
gekommen.
Wer benutzt noch Windows?
Also einen Windows-Nutzer siehst du hier
gerade. Aber ich benutze
auch Linux. Ich benutze Windows und Linux. Ich benutze
mehr Linux als Windows, aber ab und zu benutze ich auch Windows.
great
warum die feiern das ja voll ab
mac already has basically all of this
ja
warum sind die alle so krass
ich hab gedacht
da drunter gibt es jetzt 30 Milliarden
microsoft
das stimmt übrigens gar nicht
dass ich arch mit i3 benutze
Ich benutze Arch bzw. CacheUS mit KDE mittlerweile.
Warum flippen die hier jetzt so alle aus?
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, hier wird richtig hart Microslop gememt unter den Kommentaren.
Sind das Microsoft Fanboy Bots?
When you can't even make your CTO use your in-house SlopOS.
Okay, hätte ich eigentlich gedacht, dass das hier ein bisschen mehr sich drüber lustig gemacht wird, aber na gut.
Anscheinend ist das das, was MacOS gebraucht hat.
Excellent.
Achso, hier übrigens
Erschleutung, da eine Frage hin
Ich bin seit ein paar Jahren schon ziemlich
Active, was
Sportliche Betätigung angeht
Ich hab
Also ich geh fast jeden Tag joggen
Mittlerweile auch
Kann ich auch
Halbwegs schnell
Es ist immer die Frage, wie man das einschätzt
Wenn du jetzt jemanden fragst
Der 25 ist
Und seit 15 Jahren
Rennt oder so
für den ist ein 5er Pace
übelst lahm.
Für den ist das Recovery Run.
Wenn du mich fragst, mit 42
und einer, der das erst seit
mit Pausen,
seit 2,5 Jahren macht,
ist ein 5er Pace schon echt ordentlich.
Also der Marathon,
der Marathon Weltrekord,
Der wurde gelaufen mit ungefähr 2,55 pro Kilometer.
Also das ist quasi fast genau doppelt so schnell, wie ich 5 Kilometer laufen kann.
Vom Pace her.
Und danach mega im Arsch bin.
Renn die einfach 42 Kilometer.
Aber das ist eh komplett unmenschlich.
So und ich hab
Also kann ich jetzt vielleicht
An der Stelle erzählen
Also ich hab zwei
Ich hab zwei Ziele
Kurzfristig
Also mittelfristig
Kurz- bis mittelfristig und langfristig
Also mein
Wie gesagt das langfristige Ziel
Ist halt auch sehr hoch gesteckt
Das kurzfristige Ziel ist eigentlich nicht so das Ding glaube ich
Mein
also ich habe mehrere kurzfristige Ziele, aber das
eine ist, ich will Halbmarathon
Länge laufen in einer halbwegs
brauchbaren Zeit, also irgendwas so mit
6,30er Pace oder sowas
quasi 21 Kilometer
das ist auch
würde ich mal behaupten
ohne Probleme machbar, wäre es
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon, weil die längste
Strecke, die ich mal bisher gelaufen bin, war glaube ich
17,5 oder sowas Kilometer
und 17,5
Und von 17,5 Kilometer auf 21 Kilometer, ich meine, das skaliert ja nicht linear.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du sagen kannst, ich kann 10 Kilometer laufen, also kann ich auch 20, kann ich auch 30, kann ich auch 40, kann ich auch unendlich.
So ist es ja nicht.
Aber sag mal mal so, gehen halb Kilometer mehr nach 17, das ist durchaus im Bereich des Möglichen.
Also ich würde gerne eine Halbmarathon-Distanz packen, so in halb, Reddish, danke schön für den Sub.
in, ja, so mit 6,30er Pace oder sowas.
Das sind dann so ungefähr, ungefähr, weiß ich nicht,
zwei Stunden oder so, zwei Stunden fünf oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Oder zwei Stunden zwei, zwei Stunden drei oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, also ein bisschen über zwei Stunden Halbmarathon-Distanz.
Das ist so das, was ich mir so für die nächsten Wochen und Monate vorgenommen habe.
So, und dann habe ich mir überlegt, okay, was kann man denn langfristig machen,
wo man drauf hinarbeiten kann.
Und da habe ich mir überlegt,
okay, was ist denn die längste Distanz,
die du schon mal geschwommen bist,
die du gerannt bist, die du Fahrrad gefahren bist.
So, längste Distanz Fahrradfahren waren, glaube ich,
irgendwie ein paar 70 Kilometer.
Längste Distanz Rennen
waren mal 17,5 Kilometer.
Und längste Distanz...
Ja, und längste Distanz schwimmen, weiß ich nicht, mehr ist schon 20 Jahre her, aber da konnte ich einige Kilometer schwimmen.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt mal wieder anfangen und wenn ich das alles mal hinkriege, will ich mittelfristig definitiv kein Ironman.
Kannst du vergessen, werde ich nie packen.
Ich meine, Ironman ist 42 Kilometer laufen, 180 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren, 3,8 Kilometer schwimmen.
Im Leben nicht.
Ja, ist im Leben nicht, aber was ich gerne machen würde, ist die halbe Allmähndistanz, also quasi 1,9 Kilometer schwimmen, 21 Kilometer rennen und 90 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren.
Weil, das ist denke ich insofern halbwegs realistisch, weil ich schaffe, weil ich schaffe ja, genau 70.3, ich schaffe ja jetzt schon fast die einzelnen Distanzen.
so und dann ist das glaube ich durchaus realistisch zu sagen wenn man da jetzt
noch eine ganze weile übt packt man die auch mal am stück
kennst du diesen typen der irgendwann seit 20 jahren von südamerika england um
die welt läuft was ich was ich ich kenne den typen der da gab es so eine serie
auf YouTube, der ich glaube
145 Tage
jeden Tag in Iron Man
gelaufen, gerannt und
geschwommen ist, äh, gefahren ist
gerannt und geschwommen ist
145 Tage am Stück war das, glaube ich
richtig krass, ey
das, weiß nicht wie der das schafft
ohne dass sein Schienbein explodiert ist
genau, der hier
dass ohne dass ein Schienbein oder sonst was explodiert ist, keine Ahnung, wie das möglich ist.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wenn man das hier liest, ohne Scheiß, ja vor allem, ich mach das 2,5 Jahre
und ich hatte immer, was mich total zurückgeworfen hat, ich hab immer teilweise Monate und das letzte Mal ein halbes Jahr Pause gemacht.
Das hat dann immer wieder ziemlich zurückgeworfen.
Das lag an anderen Problemen, die ich hatte.
Da konnte ich mich nicht dazu aufraffen, das zu machen.
Aber jetzt, seit ein paar Monaten, geht es wieder voll steil.
Und das hier, was der Patrick schreibt, das ist wirklich so.
Man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie schnell man brauchbar in was werden kann,
wenn man einfach nur hartnäckig ist und damit anfängt.
Das ist mal egal, was es ist.
Ja
Wenn ihr
Ich meine, ihr braucht natürlich persönliche Motivation dazu
Muss jetzt kein Ironman sein
Wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ey
Ich würde gerne, keine Ahnung, Klavierspielen lernen
Oder ich würde gerne
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Schachspielen lernen
Whatever, ja
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie schnell man
Wenn man selbst motiviert ist, das zu lernen
Und das machen wir, also inneren Antrieb dazu hat
Und da
Zeit reinsteckt
wie schnell man in allen möglichen Sachen oder jonglieren lernen oder irgendwie sowas,
wie schnell man in allen möglichen Sachen gut werden kann.
Das ist viel schneller, als man denkt.
Und ein bisschen das Problem ist, was viele Leute haben,
was ich auch habe, bei ganz vielen Punkten ist,
dass man sich denkt, ach guck mal, man guckt sich dann Leute an und denkt sich,
boah alter, ist das krass, das braucht bestimmt 30 Jahre, bis man das richtig kann.
Dann lohnt sich das ja gar nicht, damit jetzt anzufangen.
Aber wenn man das wirklich machen will, ist das falsch, weil man glaubt gar nicht, wie schnell man innerhalb von ein paar Monaten ganz brauchbar werden kann. Man muss sich natürlich abschminken. Also was natürlich auch unrealistisch ist, ist die Leute, die dir immer erzählen wollen, so motivationstechnisch, ja, wenn du es nur richtig willst, dann kannst du alles schaffen. Das ist unrealistisch.
Also ich kann mir jetzt vornehmen, ich kann mir jetzt denken, ich will den Marathon Weltrekord schlagen.
Ja, das ist unmöglich.
Ich bin 42, mach das erst seit zweieinhalb Jahren, unmöglich.
Kannst du vergessen.
Also man muss das schon ein bisschen realistisch einsetzen.
Also du kannst alles schaffen, wenn du nur willst, ist übertrieben.
Aber man sollte vielleicht die bisschen abgespecktere Variante davon nehmen.
Man kann sehr vieles schaffen, wenn man will.
Und meistens schneller und besser, als man erstmal selbst für möglich hält in ganz kurzer Zeit.
Und das kommt natürlich auch, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Von Null auf halbwegs brauchbar geht viel schneller als von halbwegs brauchbar zu Weltspitze.
Ne? Also, in was
halbwegs gut werden,
ist durchaus
möglich für die meisten Leuten.
Weltspitze in irgendwas zu werden,
da kommen wir wieder dazu, kann nicht jeder schaffen.
Ja?
Aber wenn ihr jetzt sagt, Alter, ich hätte richtig
Bock darauf, jonglieren zu lernen oder sowas,
wenn ihr euch da irgendwie
Geiz angucken könnt und damit anfängt,
ich wette mit euch, in drei, vier Monaten
könnt ihr damit
easy Leute
beeindrucken, wie geil ihr jonglieren könnt.
Wenn ihr das regelmäßig übt
Wenn man da halt Bock drauf hat
Ne, das
Das muss man gar nicht unbedingt
Das, genau, das, genau, genau
Es gibt zwei Sachen
Es gibt, es gibt
Also, erstens, umso älter man wird
ist es auch schon Fortschritt,
wenn man das Niveau hält.
Muss man sich auch
immer wieder vor Augen führen, ja.
Also wenn du jetzt mit, wenn einer mit 30
anfängt, gibt er voll Gas,
rennt irgendwie sein
430er Pace über
5 Kilometer und er schafft
das dann mit 40 immer noch und mit
50 immer noch, dann
ist das richtig nice. Dann hat
er sich krass verbessert.
Wenn du siehst, in wie gut ist
er im Vergleich zu
anderen gleichaltrigen
gleichen Geschlechts. Dann hat er sich
krass verbessert, obwohl sich in Zeiten nichts verbessert
hat.
Und das nächste ist,
ja, oftmals
ist es so, wenn man
in,
also wenn man gleich schnell
Fortschritte machen will,
oder sagen wir mal, wenn man
konstant, wenn man konstant
mit einer konstanten Geschwindigkeit
Fortschritte machen will,
dann muss man
an verschiedenen Punkten
mehr
Energie reinstecken, um das zu erreichen.
So. Aber,
was natürlich auch geht,
wenn man sagt, Alter, ich, ich,
mein Ziel ist nicht Elite Runner
zu werden, dann ist es
auch okay, wenn man es nicht
übertreibt und einfach
hinnimmt,
dass man vielleicht nicht
linear irgendwie Fortschritte macht
oder schnell
Fortschritte macht, sondern dass man sagt,
okay, der Schritt...
Oh fuck, ich hab vergessen, meine Pilten zu nehmen.
Äh...
Moment.
Zack.
Das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Genau.
Und wenn man sich damit abfindet,
dass man vielleicht einfach ein bisschen länger braucht
für die einzelnen Schritte, dann ist das ja auch okay.
Also wenn man sagt, okay,
ich laufe jetzt in 6er-Pace
und ich trainiere jetzt
dreimal die Woche
strukturiert,
weil ich das gut vereinbaren kann
mit Job, Familie,
anderen Hobbys und sonst was
und dann trainiere ich für ein halbes Jahr oder für ein Jahr
und dann packe ich 530er Pace.
Gut.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, mein nächstes Ziel ist 5er Pace über 5 Kilometer,
dann könntest du jetzt ja sagen, okay, um das zu erreichen,
muss ich jetzt 5 Tage die Woche trainieren.
Du könntest aber vielleicht auch sagen, okay,
ich bleibe bei 3 Tagen die Woche,
lege vielleicht noch irgendwie ein irgendwas anderes ein,
mal irgendwie
einen vierten Tag Crosstraining mit
irgendwas anderem, wo ich Bock drauf habe
und akzeptiere halt, dass ich vielleicht
nicht in einem halben Jahr
von 35 auf einen Fünfer-Pace
komme, sondern dafür ein Jahr brauche.
Das geht auch. Also
man muss ja nicht dann den Anspruch
haben, okay, ich will
immer linear da Fortschritte machen
und da mehr Zeit reinstecken, weil
irgendwann, wenn man kein Profi ist in irgendeinem
Gebiet, kann man halt nicht. Ja, man kann
halt nicht sich hinsetzen und sagen,
Ich trainiere jetzt sechs Tage die Woche für zwei Stunden, wenn du noch Familie hast, wenn du noch andere Verpflichtungen hast, wenn du arbeiten gehen musst und sonst noch was machen willst.
Der Tag hat nur 24 Stunden, das kriegst du halt nicht hin.
Ich hab den Luxus.
Ich hab keine Kinder, ich hab keine Frau, ich kann Homeoffice arbeiten.
Ich bin ansonsten, was Hobbys angeht, außer hier Bastelkram, sehr genügsam.
Ich habe Zeit, ja. Ich kann fünf bis sechs Mal die Woche trainieren gehen. Ist gar kein Problem. Und ich gehe eigentlich, ich gehe eher sechs Mal die Woche trainieren mittlerweile. Ich mache eigentlich nur Pause, wenn mein Garmin Trainingsplan Generator sagt, hör auf, mach mal am Tag Pause. Ansonsten wird jeden Tag...
Und auch wichtig ist, was auch wichtig ist, selbst wenn man jetzt die super krasse Motivation hat, gerade am Anfang das langsame Hochschrauben.
Ich habe auch den Fehler gemacht, ich habe 2025, zweite Hälfte 2025, ich habe ein halbes Jahr fast nichts gemacht.
Bis jetzt wieder hier Anfang 2026.
Ich habe fast ein halbes Jahr nichts gemacht.
So, und ich habe den Fehler gemacht, ich habe wieder, nachdem ich das jetzt ja mehr oder weniger so weit überwunden habe, meine Probleme, dass ich zu 90% gut klarkomme, 95% gut klarkomme, habe ich wieder richtig Motivation gehabt, anzufangen zu joggen und ich habe es halt übertrieben, weil ich mir gedacht habe, ey, du musst jetzt mal das verlorene halbe Jahr Training, musst du jetzt halt mal schnell wieder aufholen.
und da habe ich es halt voll übertrieben
und bin auch
quasi gerannt, wo mir noch das Schienbein
wehgetan hat und sowas
ja, so ein bisschen zwicken und so ist normal
aber mir hat wirklich der ganze Lauf das Schienbein wehgetan
und dann hatte ich das Problem
dann habe ich mal mein Schienbein so drüber gefahren
mit der Hand, ja
so ein bisschen uneben ist das Schienbein
immer, wenn man da so drauf drückt und dran reibt
aber ich hatte so einen richtigen
jetzt, der ist so gut wie weg, ja
ich hatte so einen richtigen Knubbel auf dem Schienbein.
Das hat man auch,
wenn man so am Schienbein runtergeguckt hat
und draufgeläuft, hat man das richtig gesehen.
So ein Knubbel am Schienbein.
Und wenn man da drauf gedrückt hat
und nebendran gedrückt hat, hat das auch wehgetan.
Und da dachte ich mir so, okay,
das ist definitiv nicht gut.
Und da habe ich dann,
habe ich drüber gelesen,
das ist etwas, was viele Läufer haben,
die es zu sehr übertreiben.
Da entzündet sich die Haut am Knochen,
Am Schienbeinknochen entzündet sich die Haut und dann schwillt es ein bisschen an, da kriegt man so Knuppel.
Und das tut halt auch weh und auf Dauer ist es nicht gut.
Auf Dauer, wenn du es total übertreibst, kann es sogar sein, dass du irgendwie Schienbeinrisse kriegst durch Ermüdungserscheinungen.
Also das ist nicht gut.
Deswegen, ich war dann auch mal bei meinem Hausarzt, der hat ein bisschen drauf rumgedrückt und gesagt,
das müssen wir mal ein bisschen beobachten.
Wenn das länger bleibt, müssen wir es vielleicht mal röntgen, ob da nicht was ist.
Aber jetzt soll ich mir das erstmal angucken.
Und als ich das nächste Mal da war, war auch wieder alles gut.
Hat nicht mehr wehgetan und ist wieder weggegangen.
Also war wirklich nur die Knochenhaut, die da ein bisschen entzündet ist.
Und dann habe ich so gemacht, ich muss ja dann notgedrungen mal 3-4 Wochen noch mal Pause machen.
Noch einen Monat so ungefähr.
Bis das wieder komplett weg war.
Das einzige, was ich in der Zeit gemacht habe, ist halt ab und zu ein bisschen Fahrrad gefahren und so.
Aber das war es halt.
Also irgendwas, was nicht so Impact aufs Schienbein hat.
und dann habe ich es gemacht
über
einen Zeitraum von drei Wochen
habe ich das langsam
hochgefahren, ja
ich bin gerannt
so 35 Minuten
dann habe ich zwei Tage Pause gemacht
bin wieder 35 Minuten gerannt, habe ich wieder
zwei Tage Pause gemacht
danach bin ich 35 Minuten, habe mal einen Tag Pause
gemacht, so, dann bin ich
mal 40, 45 Minuten
gerannt, habe wieder ein, zwei Tage Pause gemacht
So, das habe ich dann über drei Wochen oder vier Wochen wieder langsam hochgefahren und seitdem ist es gar kein Problem mehr.
Seitdem kann ich wieder jeden Tag Rennen gehen und die Tage, wo ich nicht Rennen gehe, mache ich entweder Crosstraining mit Inlineskates fahren
oder wenn mein Trainingsplan sagt, dass ich Recovery machen soll, dann mache ich manchmal einfach an dem Tag auch gar nichts.
Und wenn er sagt, dass ich Restday einlegen soll, lege ich einen Restday ein.
Das kommt so alle, weiß ich nicht, alle sechs, sieben Tage oder so kommt das mal vor, dass er sagt, ich soll mich ausruhen.
Das ist dann aber auch wichtig.
Man muss sich ja auch komplett erholen, sonst zackt das Ganze.
Sonst hängst du immer da so halb erholt rum.
Das ist auch nichts.
So, und wenn ich jetzt mal in meine Garmin Connect gucke, gucken wir mal kurz.
Kann ich euch auch zeigen, wie viel ich hier geflitzt bin.
Long Run.
All running activities.
Running reports.
Also ich bin die letzten vier Wochen, bin ich 137 Kilometer gerannt.
Wie gesagt, nicht bewegt. Es geht wirklich nur ums Joggen schrägst durch Rennen.
Also normale Sachen, die ich zu Fuß gelaufen bin, sind da nicht drin.
Das ist reine Joggenzeit.
joggen kilometer running activity also bin letzten vier wochen bin ich 137 kilometer gerannt das
macht eben knapp fünf kilometer am tag und ich hatte 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 tage
8 Tage, wo ich nicht gelaufen bin.
Aber davon 3 Tage
Inlineskates-Cross-Training.
So.
Also hatte ich quasi 5 Tage,
5 Resting-Days in 4 Wochen.
Und damit komme ich gut klar.
Im Durchschnitt quasi so
1,2 Tage die Woche.
Gut.
Zack.
Magst du alte Flitzer, ja?
So sieht's aus.
Und das macht auch richtig Bock,
weil du siehst halt, gerade beim Joggen,
das ist so ein Ding, du siehst permanentes
Improvement. Gerade wenn du so viel
machst, ja.
Du siehst permanentes Improvement.
Ja, du hast nicht so krasses Improvement
wie am Anfang.
Ja, als ich jetzt nach einem halben Jahr wieder
angefangen hab, war's für mich schon
anstrengend, die große
Runde mit 6,45
zu rennen. Jetzt renn ich,
da war es richtig anstrengend.
Jetzt renne ich die große Runde mit 6,15
6,15er Pace
und es fühlt sich easy an.
Man sieht halt permanent
permanent Improvement.
Das ist halt nice. Deswegen ist halt auch
so eine Fitness App geil.
Weil in der Fitness App kannst du gucken
das letzte
halbe Jahr Improvement. Und das ist
wie bei YouTube grüne Pfeile
oder generell Pfeile in Grafen
und den Diagrammen, die nach oben gehen, sind motivierend.
Warum eigentlich Capture Card plus Deskflow und kein KVM?
Weil es länger dauert zum Umschalten.
Und weil ich nicht richtig streamen kann.
Wie soll ich mit KVM einen Linux-Desktop gescheit streamen?
Das müsste ich ja dann trotzdem capturen.
Hier habe ich ja OBS laufen.
Ja, also...
Oder meinst du eine IP-KVM?
So eine IP-basierte KVM.
Wo du das Fenster aufmachen kannst und dann gucken kannst.
Ja, da ist das Delay größer.
Da habe ich auch eine.
Die haben wir öfters jetzt auch schon für die Nassgeschichten, Raspberry Pi Sachen und so verwendet.
Da ist das Delay aber viel größer als hier.
Also Deskflow mit Capture Card.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist eine 240 Hz Capture Card.
Achso, ich bin ja auch dumm, ich gucke im falschen OBS.
Das ist eine PCI Express Capture Card, die 240 FPS capturen kann.
Und das in Kombination ist nahezu kein Delay spürbar.
Also 15 Millisekunden oder so, das ist hier für Desktopbetrieb überhaupt nichts.
Competitive Shooter würde ich jetzt nicht darüber spielen, aber vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und ich kann halt hier alles hin und her schalten.
Ich kann hier meine Emotes einblenden drüber und alles.
Und ich kann halt zwischen
Das ist im Prinzip ein Ersatz für meine VM-Lösung
Früher hatte ich eine VM
Hatte ich auf dem zweiten Desktop eine VM, da konnte ich hier
Zwischen umschalten, so
Und das kann ich jetzt im Prinzip auch machen zwischen
Windows Desktop und Linux Desktop
Das ist für mich das perfekte Setup
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal Updates machen
Update
Moment, was zum
Was macht es da?
Speedtest
Okay, keine Ahnung
So, erstmal gucken, was für Supply Chain Angriffe
Ich mir hier einfange
WL Clipboard
Git
Kann ich nicht WL Clipboard auch so installieren?
Guck mal, WL Clipboard
Git
Ist 231
Und hier ist
WL Clipboard noch 230.
Ja, suck, Alter.
Ich würde ja gerne das aus offiziellen
aus offiziellen Package-Quellen.
Warte mal, wir gucken mal kurz.
Weil ich brauche das
für Copy-Paste von
VM auf Windows.
2-3
Ach, 2-3 ist das letzte Stable Release
2-3-1
Ist dann quasi hier
Master
Naja gut, dann brauch ich das
Na gut
Wir hoffen einfach mal
Wir werden nicht Supply Chain
Attacked
Gucken wir mal.
Sieht nicht nach krassen Supply Chain Attacks aus, hä?
Was wird der eigentlich alles updaten?
Jetbrains Toolbox?
Jeterino Bin?
Gucken wir mal.
Researchen wir mal.
und denken wir mal von aus passiert nichts
dort fahren geil immer von aus passiert nichts und chatarino bin
immer von aus ist nichts pro weise kommt direkt von chatarino
Geht nicht.
Geh mal von außen, wir werden nicht Supply Chain
Attacked. Oder upgraden einfach.
Was die ganzen
Flags machen, das kann ich dir sagen.
So halbwegs.
Devil
macht, dass der auch alle Minus-Git-Packages
updatet.
Ähm.
Upgrade all?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Ich hab mich da irgendwann mal dran gewöhnt,
dass so muss das Command aussehen.
Aber hier,
wir können,
für solche Dinger ist Chat-GPT noch gut.
Explain.
Bam. Mal gucken, ob da was
Sinnvolles rauskommt.
Sync Install Mode.
Okay. Upgrade. Checks.
Okay. Der guckt nach, ob es neue Sachen gibt.
Refresh Package Database.
Force Refresh Package Database.
Upgrade Packages. All Packages.
Und Git Packages.
Excellent.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Da Vinci Resolve
könnte ich, by the way, mal wieder eininstallen.
Das backt rum.
Hat Arch Linux
jetzt nicht standardmäßig...
Äh, nicht Arch Linux, CacheOS?
Nicht jetzt so einen
Pac-Man, so einen neuen Pac-Man-Rapper
als Default-Package-Manager?
Oder wollen sie einführen?
vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Irgendwas in Rust geritten ist, wahrscheinlich.
Weil heutzutage alles in Rust rewritet werden muss.
Chat, wisst ihr, was auch unbedingt in Rust rewritet werden muss?
Nee, nee, nee, nicht Paro, was anderes.
Ist anscheinend standardmäßig an, ja.
Also hier, meine Afg-Klo-Anzeige, die muss dringend in Rust rewritet werden.
Seht ihr, wie laggy die ist?
Da siehst ihr den kompletten Refresh.
Also das ist wirklich gar nichts.
Oder was sagt ihr?
Also das ist definitiv nicht blazingly fast, diese Anzeige.
Der Fiat Champ, oh hör mal auf.
Ich muss, Leute, der Fiat Champ, ich hab Glück.
Ich muss den Fiat Champ nie wieder neu programmieren.
Irgendjemand hat sich vom Fiat Champ die Sachen abgeguckt und ein Home Assistant Add-on erstellt.
Was er jetzt maintained.
Das heißt, Fiat Champ braucht man gar nicht mehr.
Ich muss mich nicht mehr drum kümmern.
Also ich hab mich vorher auch nicht drum gekümmert, aber jetzt müsste ich mich gar nicht dran kümmern.
Shelly APM, ja genau, das meine ich.
Ähm, so
Go-Quarium
Gibt's das auch?
GitHub
Asti-Quarium
Implementation in Go
Ja, aber kann die auch alle
Nice Features? Ne, kann die
Bestimmt nicht
Die hat bestimmt kein
Haifisch und
Timmy schwimmt nicht vorbei
Wobei, Timmy schwimmt vorbei
Cool, Retro-Term
Ist das das, was aussieht wie ein CRT-Fernseher?
Wenn ja, dann kenne ich das
Max, hast du das in Hamburg mit Timmy mitbekommen?
Nee.
Ich dachte, Timmy ist irgendwo in Dänemark gestrandet oder so.
Vor ein paar Monaten.
Moment, das muss ich copy-pasten, das funzt nicht.
Moment, das muss ich mir gerade noch mal angucken.
Was zum...
Was bin ich lesend, Alter?
Wahl am Kreuz.
Timmy Regisseur spricht über Morddrohungen.
Die Hope stirbt zuletzt.
Moment, die haben...
Die haben ein Theaterstück
über Timmy den Wahl gemacht.
But why?
Ja gut, dass sich da jetzt wieder
irgendwelche Leute angegriffen fühlen.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Kann schon sein.
Ja, Morddrohungen und solche Sachen
haben ja nicht nur Islamisten
für sich gepachtet.
Christliche Leute können sowas auch.
Wobei der Aufschrei wahrscheinlich
deutlich größer gewesen wäre,
wenn es eine Mohammed-Referenz gegeben hätte.
Dann wäre mein Aufschrei wahrscheinlich richtig krass gewesen.
Komplett eskaliert.
Twitter auch.
Aber es gibt überall Verrückte.
Es gab auch Leute mit Fischbrötchen, die vor Ort Timmy angefolgt haben.
Ja, die sind komplett durch gewesen damals alle.
Ich war ja froh, dass dieses Thema Timmy endlich dann wieder verschwunden ist, als es wieder weg war.
Mir ging das so krass am Arsch vorbei.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Das war mir so egal.
Das war mir tatsächlich so egal, dass ich noch nicht mal drüber twittern wollte, reden wollte,
wie sehr es mich abfuckt, dass die Leute über sowas Sinnloses reden.
So egal war mir das.
Es gibt ja Sachen, die sind mir egal, aber mich nervt es,
dass andere Leute da so drauf einsteigen.
Aber Timmy war es mir so egal, dass es mich noch nicht mal genervt hat.
Können wir den Wahl-O-Mat machen?
Da gibt es wieder einen.
Ach, der Wahl-O-Mat für den Wahl.
Okay.
Finde den besten Weg für Timmy.
Mit der App, was es nicht alles gibt, Alter.
Was gibt's da so für Fragen?
Da gibt's noch...
Da ist noch gar nicht Timmy.
Du meinst jetzt den echten Valomat.
Ich weiß nicht, wann in Hessen wieder gewählt wird.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung, Alter.
FDP kannst du ja komplett vergessen.
Ich habe ja die letzten Jahre öfters FDP gewählt.
In der Mangelung irgendwas anderes, wofür ich mich entscheiden konnte.
Aber das macht ja jetzt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr.
Die kommen...
Die kommen eh nicht in...
in irgendwelche
Parlamente mehr rein.
Dann...
Dann keine Ahnung.
Dann einfach Tierschutzpartei oder irgendwie sowas.
Wobei ich auch gelesen hab,
Tierschutzpartei soll wohl gar nicht so ohne sein.
Hinter dem Deckmantel des Tierschutzes.
Das hab ich irgendwann mal in einem Artikel drüber gelesen.
So, haben wir jetzt alles geupdatet hier?
Upgrade.
Warum macht er jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Upgrade mache,
neuen Speedtest für die Mirrors?
Sollte dann nicht einmal die Woche oder so vielleicht ausreichen?
Weil das ist ja nicht...
Das dauert ja ewig...
Ewig und drei Tage, wie meine Oma immer gesagt hat.
Bis der hier überhaupt anfängt zu upgraden.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So.
Gibt es Jetbrain-Software-Updates,
gibt es Rust Rover-Upgrades,
C-Line-Upgrades und Rider-Updates.
Let's go.
Hm.
Sollte ich auch mal von Fedora auf Casio S wechseln?
Nö, solltest du nicht.
Wenn du zufrieden bist mit Fedora, gibt es keinen Grund zu wechseln.
das weiß ich nicht das war das das weiß ich tatsächlich der f-programmer ich ich vermeide
es mit den leuten über solche über solche themen über solche themen zu sprechen ja weil du nie
weißt wie die so drauf sind also wie gesagt ich habe schon mal erzählt ich habe eine nachbar der
hat mir erzählt als als corona als corona am start war als moslem und da ist der meinung
Corona war eine Strafe Gottes.
Oder eine Strafe Allahs.
Corona.
Und als er mir das erzählt hat,
ich wusste gar nicht, wie ich da drauf reagieren soll.
Ich habe einfach gar nichts gesagt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, aha, okay, na ja, na dann.
Was sollst du
aus sowas sagen, Alter?
Aber anscheinend,
das ist so ein Ding,
was mir bei vielen Religionen aufgefallen ist,
die haben oftmals das Gefühl,
Gott würde sie irgendwie bestrafen oder so.
Das hätte ja nichts Besseres zu tun.
Corona und Kek-Alu, ja.
Na gut, Kek-Alu, Kek-Alu,
Kek-Alu war ja eher
Bill Gates impft uns Mikrochips, genau.
Das war eher Kek-Alu.
Egal, aber das Thema
habe ich echt keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist komplett tot diskutiert.
So, Updates gemacht.
Kekwt.
Jetbrains Sachen geupdatet.
Da können wir uns doch mal angucken, was auf GitHub so trendet heute.
Date this week.
Okay, ich weiß, das wird jetzt wieder 99% AI, AI, AI.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Okay, AI.
Geht schon gut los.
AI.
AI?
Nicht AI?
Keine Ahnung.
AI?
Wahrscheinlich AI.
Wahrscheinlich nicht AI?
AI.
Nice.
Top.
Okay, was ist das?
Kaneo.
All you need, nothing you don't.
Open Source Project Management.
Ihh, Projektmanagement.
Okay, schon mal gut, dass das als Container-Image kommt.
Aber was macht man damit jetzt?
Das ist quasi ein Kanban-Board.
Wetten.
Chat.
Wir haben uns die Software noch nicht angeguckt.
Wollen wir mal raten, in was die written ist?
Ich tippe drauf, das ist Elektron.
Was sagt ihr?
In was ist das written?
Pass auf, jetzt kommen die Leute,
die sagen Rust und Tauri oder so.
Könnte auch sein.
Ich sag, das ist Elektron.
Atomshell.
Lul.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Es ist written in...
TypeScript?
TypeScript? Das spricht schon mal hart für Elektron.
Okay, wie kriege ich denn jetzt raus, ob das written in Elektron ist?
Gescheit.
Apps?
Ist das nicht eine Web-Anwendung?
Nee, dann bräuchten die ja keinen Docker-Container.
Wir können Package-Chasing gucken.
Package-Chasing.
Was da drin ist.
Äh...
Wo sind... Wo... Wo...
Wo sind die... Chat?
Ich bin zu dumm. Wo sind... Wo sind die Dependencies?
Dot Enf Mono?
Mono?
PNPM-Block?
Okay.
Durchschnittliche
JavaScript-Dependencies
von einem JavaScript-Projekt.
Hahaha! JavaScript-Pack
W, Alter!
15.000 Zeilen!
Irgendwelche Dependencies, Alter.
Jetzt,
wir hatten es doch gestern,
Wir haben uns doch gestern von Supply Chain angriffen
Und dass JavaScript Sachen da
In letzten Monaten, Jahren besonders anfällig werden
Das liegt auch unter anderem daran
Dass da ja, Moment, Moment, wir müssen gucken
Ist odd
Odd, ist, ist odd
Ist das da auch, oh ne, ist nicht drin
Ist even, ist even drin
Nein, auch nicht, okay
Okay, und wie kriegen wir denn jetzt raus
In was das written ist
Okay, da wird es, da wird es nicht drin sein
Packages vielleicht? Deploy? Keine Ahnung.
Apps vielleicht?
Chart? Das ist ein Helm-Chart oder was?
Okay, da muss das irgendwo drin sein.
Lips.
Ey, das ist was anderes.
Ono TS.
What?
Keine Ahnung.
Apps.
Web, Site, Doc, API.
Okay, RP.
Package Chasen.
Ist based auf...
...Hono.
Was ist Hono?
Web Framework, Build for Webstand.
Okay, das Backend ist based on Hono.
Nie gehört.
Aber das ist ja nichts verwunderliches.
JavaScript Frameworks, da kannst du...
Nur weil du vor einem halben Jahr dir mal eine Übersicht angeguckt hast,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das da drinnen schon drinnen gewesen ist.
Okay, das ist based auf Hono.
Drizzle ist ein...
Das ist Entity Framework Core für JavaScript, gell?
Drizzle.
JavaScript Checkers.
Ist doch so, oder?
Das sieht jetzt aber eher nach plain SQL aus.
Okay, kein Plan.
Das ist basiert auf Hono.
Nicht Elektron.
Aber anscheinend ist das Web-Frontend im Browser und das Backend ist dann auf Hono-Base.
Nie gehört.
Weiß nicht.
Kennt jemand von euch Hono?
Hono.js?
Ist mir neu, habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Web-Framework, Build on Web Standards.
Const-App, New Hono.
Okay, das ist quasi so was wie Express, nur in neu.
So was in der Richtung.
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade so einfällt?
Die JavaScript-Entwickler sind das komplette Gegenteil der Go-Entwickler, was Dependencies angeht.
In Go wird schon immer rumgeheult, wenn einer nicht irgendwas nur mit Standard-Library macht.
Und in JavaScript wirst du scherb angeguckt, wenn du einfachste Dinger mit Standard-Library machst und nicht irgendein Framework importierst.
Das Package hat ja 453 Weekly Downloads.
Soll ich dir mal zeigen, was noch viele Weekly Downloads hat?
IstOdd hat 1,1 Millionen Weekly Downloads.
Warum? Tja.
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
JavaScript.
Aber da sieht man, wie anfällig solche Sachen eben gerade sind.
Gerade JavaScript-Sachen, wie anfällig die sind für Supply Chain Angriffe.
Aber jetzt stellt euch mal vor.
Guck mal, da dependet einiges dran.
Und dann dependet wieder noch mehr dran und sonst was.
Unknown odd. What?
Every.
Every is odd function is even function in one package.
Das ist quasi ein Meta-Package für Is Odd, Is Even.
Ja, was gibt, Alter?
Ja, was gibt?
Wenn es doch nicht genug gibt.
Is Odd, Is Even.
Wie viel hat dann Is Even?
ist eben hat auch jetzt eben auch noch 453.000 downloads aber aber es hat eine
dependency ach so moment logisch logisch ob wir es
nur ob es die ist eben basiert auf ist und im prinzip ist es eben negativ ist
ort
Ah, das tut weh.
JavaScript.
Kann wer eine Lötkolben empfehlen?
Ja, ja.
Lötkolben, das Handwerk.
Den hier.
Das ist der beste Lötkolben hier.
Für die Finger.
Der ist ja exzellent, ne?
Das ist übrigens, ähm, bevor das jetzt jemand hier für bare Münze nimmt
Das war, glaube ich, eine Satire-Werbung im Nachhinein
Ja, aber ich kann dir eine Lötstation empfehlen
Und zwar, die ich hab, seit Jahren schon, da gibt's bestimmt eine neuere von
Ich hab eine Ersa Icon Nano
Und das Ding find ich, boah, ey, dieses komische Zeug kannst du hier vergessen
Das Ding finde ich enorm pog.
Guck mal, was Amazon dazu sagt.
Okay, die gibt es...
Also das Ding finde ich enorm pog, weil...
Was hat der...
Das ist doch ein KI-Bild, oder?
Kind mit schwarzem Gürtel und...
Was genau hat das mit der Lötstation zu tun?
Man weiß es nicht genau.
Zumindest, was ich an der Lötstation geil finde, ist der Lötkolben.
Der ist nämlich nur so klein, wie so ein großer Stift.
Und hat ein flexibles Kabel.
Und das ist richtig nice.
Und es heizt auch so schnell.
Macht richtig Bock, damit zu arbeiten.
Aber es gibt auch deutlich günstigere.
recht beliebt sind ja diese dinger zum programmieren
diese diese diese mit kam wurde wo du wo du firma es gibt doch diese lötkollen
wo die firma drauf drauf flaschen kannst und welle und welle habe ich auch was allerdings
nichts direkt zum löten sondern nur zum unterstützen ich habe von weller so eine
Metallplatte mit so Halterungen
drauf, wo man seine Dinger, die man
löten möchte, fest
klipsen kann.
Sagt mir nichts.
Es gibt schon
Wireless-Lötkolben.
Gibt schon welche mit Akku.
Ist das hier nicht ein Akku?
Ist der nicht mit Akku? Doch, der ist mit Akku.
Das ist einer von denen,
wo du Firmware drauf flashen kannst.
Custom Firmware
für Nötkolben.
Hat er keinen Akku?
Ach ne, hat er nicht.
Doch, oder?
Okay, dann habe ich nichts gesagt.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Verstehe ich, wenn du was kleines haben willst.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich.
Ich habe auch regelmäßig Platzprobleme mit meiner Station.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Ich habe euch ja vor einem halben Jahr erzählt,
ich habe mir einen extra Tisch bestellt,
um hier Streaming-Bastel-Bastel-Ecke zu bauen, gell?
Erinnert sich vielleicht noch irgendeiner dran.
Der Tisch steht seit einem halben Jahr im Flur, im Karton,
und ich habe noch nicht weitergemacht.
Horstchamp.
Und mein Plan,
meinen Indoor-Trainer fürs Fahrrad
endlich mal hinten ordentlich
in die Ecke zu stellen, dass ich das
auch noch ein bisschen aufrüsten kann mit einem eigenen Monitor
und so davor, hab ich auch nicht gemacht.
Ich bin einfach so ein fauler Sack.
Wie viele Sterne hat das eigentlich?
Oh no, Repositories
Hat wie viel Sterne?
32.000, okay, scheint recht beliebt zu sein
Was? Ersa PC
70, also Ersa macht
Prinzipiell gute Dinger
Aber das ist doch auch mit Station, oder nicht?
Ah ne, nur mit Halterung
Aber wo ist denn dann das Ding dran?
Das kommt dann direkt in die Steckdose, oder was?
Keine Ahnung
Kann ich dir nichts zu sagen
Aber er ist ein ganz brauchbarer Dinger
Boah
eine gute Bewertung.
Was mir wichtig ist und was ich jetzt hier nicht so richtig erkenne,
hat er ein flexibles Kabel.
Weil ich finde flexible Kabel sehr angenehm.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so flexibel aus.
Aber das kann man schlecht erkennen.
Also Chat, vielleicht habt ihr da eine Empfehlung.
Ich habe nur die Lötstation.
Kann sonst nichts sagen.
Was haben wir hier noch?
In Videos.
In Videos ist Alternative Frontend
to YouTube.
Aha.
Okay.
Was soll das?
Ein self-gehostetes
YouTube Frontend?
What?
Okay, sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Webseite von vor 10 Jahren.
Okay.
Ja gut, blockt alle Ads, okay.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Ist schon seit Jahren tot, der anscheinend nicht.
Hier wird
Zeug geupdatet.
Prepare for next release.
Fein nicht dead geht zu sehen.
Wie wäre es mit
Hash include
Was?
Wie? Wo?
Möchtest du damit jetzt sagen,
du hättest gerne Includes in C, die Wildcards können.
Oder du hättest gerne Include-Anweisungen in CSS.
Oder gerne Include-Anweisungen in JavaScript, die Wildcard-CSS importieren kann.
Oder was jetzt?
Es ist auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, keine gute Idee.
Egal, was es davon ist.
Ach so meinst du das?
Ja, das sah hässlich aus.
Das stimmt.
Soll ich euch Matrix 17
zeigen,
wie ihr
oftmals
DNS-Blockaden
und
Firewall-Sachen und so
umgehen könnt?
Ihr braucht
aber einen externen Server, der per SSH
erreichbar ist.
oftmals ist ssh nämlich nicht geblockt
gerade wenn ihr admin seid weil ssh gebraucht wird so und was ihr machen könnt das gute ist
halt ssh ist verschlüsselt kann eh keiner gucken was ihr da macht ssh kann minus d
Genau.
Du kannst mit SSH minus...
Nee, nee, nee, nicht minus L.
Du kannst mit SSH minus D
kannst du einen Socks-Proxy aufmachen.
Also du machst dann quasi sowas hier sinngemäß.
SSH minus D.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal drin hab hier.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die Syntax so stimmt.
Sowas hier in der Richtung machst du.
Dann macht der lokal
dann macht der Lokal
ein Socks-Proxy auf
auf Port 8080.
Dann könnt ihr beispielsweise in euren
Firefox gehen.
Wo ist denn der Unterschied zu einem Jump-Host,
dass du nichts machen musst, außer deinen Browser
da drauf umstellen. Und mit einem Jump-Host
ist es natürlich auch schwierig zu browsen.
So, dann geht ihr hier Proxy.
Wo stellt man diesen Scheiß
mittlerweile um? Proxy-Settings.
So und da würdet ihr dann im Endeffekt einstellen Localhost als Soxproxy, Localhost Port 8080.
Und dann könntet ihr über SSH surfen einfach.
Also ihr braucht nur ein Gegenstück, was SSH kann.
Und dann könnt ihr über Soxproxy getunnelt über SSH surfen und kommt quasi auf dieser Kiste dann raus.
damit kann man viel umgehen wenn man es darauf anlegt und ssh freigeschaltet ist
es gibt noch zig andere varianten wo man auch ein gegenserver im internet braucht
aber wenn ssh freigeschaltet ist es das mit abstand die einfachste so habe ich
beispielsweise auch mein youtube premium früher in indien abgeschlossen für 350
indische rupien ich habe mir bei digital ocean vm in
Bangalore gemietet,
hab SSH Socksproxy
drauf gemacht,
YouTube Premium verlängert,
vor allem wieder gelöscht, hat mich dann im Endeffekt
1,20 Euro gekostet
oder so.
Wenn überhaupt, weniger.
20 Cent oder so.
Geht das noch mit ausländischem YouTube Premium?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ob das noch...
Also es ging nicht mehr.
Vielleicht gibt es jetzt aber Tricks, dass es wieder geht.
SSH.
Also das habe ich schon mal gelesen.
Das habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Dass du quasi direkt ein Device hast.
Und sowas wie Layer 2.
Atom ist Layer 3 Device.
Tab ist Layer 2 Device.
oder umgedreht.
Weiß ich. Zumindest, ja genau.
Zumindest, dass du sogar ein Layer 3 Tunnel
machen kannst. Also SSH, ohne Scheiß,
SSH ist eines der
geilsten Tools, die es
gibt. Es zahlt
sich enorm aus, sich mal
wirklich in der Tiefe mit SSH zu
beschäftigen. SSH kann
so viel.
Und du kannst
so viel Zeug tunneln, tricksen
mit SSH.
Du kannst fast alles mit SSH irgendwie umgehen
Du kannst ja sogar über SSH tunneln
Wenn du einfach nur
Quasi Text übertragen kannst
Also du kannst ja quasi Standard in und Standard out
In Netzwerkdevices pipen und sowas
Du kannst mit SSH
Ich sag mal zu 99%
Kommst du mit SSH
Aus, wenn du dich irgendwie tunneln musst
Solange du eine Gegenstelle irgendwo hast
Das H ist eines der geilsten
Tools, die es gibt.
Hast du irgendwas mit Rennsport am Hut?
Nee, gar nicht.
Sportsachen, die ich gucke, ich gucke ganz gerne
nebenbei ein bisschen Radsport.
bisschen triathlon ein bisschen so etwas wenn schwimmen wm ist und sowas guckt
es aber hauptsächlich nebenbei weil ich finde das ist so eine gute riese
berieselung nebenbei so also dann wissen wir jetzt was die
woche trendet eigentlich nichts wirklich spannendes dabei das ganze kai zeug
haben wir außen vor gelassen dann schauen wir doch mal okay language
gucken wir doch mal was kommt die rast fans kommen ob etwas sinnvolles in was
trendet diese woche
weil wir hatten diesmal erst auch erstaunlich wenig was zeug das hat man
schon mal hat wer accelerated gpu terminal emulator
ok ist das der alternative eine sinnvolle alternative zu western to run
In Desktops and Browsers.
Das kenne ich noch nicht.
Was kann das Tolles?
Rio Term.
Es ist written in Rust.
Und in Slang.
Moment, in Metal?
Ist das macOS only?
Aber was macht man im Terminal,
wenn man es beschleunigt?
Ja, zum Beispiel schnell Text rendern.
Guck.
Wenn ich Terminal Text rendere, dann wird meine GPU beansprucht.
Oder auch nicht.
Lul.
Achso, ich habe falsch sortiert.
Sort.
Nach.
GPU.
Ja, guck.
mein Terminal
verursacht
GPU-Auslastung.
Dadurch, dass es eben halt auch
mit GPU-Unterstützung rendert.
Der kann jetzt quasi schneller Text outputten,
weil er per
GPU-Unterstützung
kann es Doomrunnen, garantiert.
100 Pro. Muss ich gar nicht nachgucken.
Warum liegt
dann Westtime im Download-Ordner?
Weil...
Ich glaube, weil das aus dem Art User Repo selbst kompilieren wollte.
Und das war mir zu doof.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Ach ne, ich habe normales Westterm installiert.
Genau, ich habe normales Westterm installiert, hatte einen Bug.
Und wollte gucken, ob das neueste Westterm besser funktioniert.
Und seitdem habe ich einfach nichts mehr gemacht daran.
So, was kann das jetzt? Was kann das besonders, besonders gut?
Warum sollte ich Rio verwenden?
What?
Was sind denn jetzt die großen Vorteile?
Warum ist das denn
Warum ist das denn jetzt das Terminal
Was ich verwenden sollte
Open Source and Trusted
By thousands of Developers
Ja und warum?
Also was kann das geiles?
Features
Okay, also
VI-Mode, Hints
Features, was?
Okay, Features
Links
Cliff-Protokoll
Alter
Kann das Taps?
Multi-Window, okay
Schön
panels split panels ok shell integration
6 er das ist für bilder im bilder im terminal kitty keyboard kitty graphics item image protokoll ok
navigation
Also ich sehe jetzt nicht so richtig, warum ich da jetzt umsteigen sollte.
Rio Terminal.
Half-Accelerated GPU Terminal Emulator powered by WebG...
WebGPU?
Ist das unter der Haube
ein Browser oder was?
Oder wie? Oder wo? Oder was?
Oder wie? Hä?
Moment.
Leute, seit ich
meinen Swap erhöht habe, ist
mein Browser viel langsamer geworden.
Ach, das ist Wasm
oder wie?
Auf was passiert das denn?
Yo, Graphics?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich werde das jetzt einfach mal installieren und mal öffnen und gucken, was passiert.
Rio.
Oh, Alter!
Oh, oh, ist das laggy.
Press Enter, okay.
Oh, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht schön gethemed,
ja, okay.
Font-Rendering sieht erstmal
in Ordnung aus.
Terminals unkonfiguriert, zackt eh immer.
So, Wim, Config, Rio, Config-Tommel.
Okay, was sind denn Rio Term Default Key Bindings?
Key Bindings.
Okay.
Was sind denn die Default Key Bindings?
Split.
Wie splitte ich was?
Split Action Right
Zoom, gibt es sowas?
Ah, das geht anscheinend nicht, hä?
Split
Split Action Split Right
Split Close Split
So Maximize Split gibt es nicht
Das fehlt mir schon mal
Ja, was hat, was sind denn die
Hier, Default Keybindings, da
Mac OS, ja
Linux BSD
Okay, copy
Create new window, Ctrl-Shift-N
Oh, nein, falsch zusammen
Ctrl-Shift-N
Ach, new window, okay
Create new tab, Ctrl-Shift-T
Okay
Increase font size, Ctrl-Plus
Äh, was?
Control...
Ach, Control plus.
Okay.
Tab.
Ich will wissen, wie man splittet.
Split right.
Control shift.
Control shift R.
Äh.
Control shift.
Jetzt hat er gesplittet.
Okay.
Okay, das funzt.
Ctrl-Shift
Kann man sonst noch splitten?
Split
Split down, Ctrl-Shift-D
Okay, ja
So, jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann ich jetzt
dieses Ding hier zoomen?
Okay, Resizen geht
Also es fühlt sich sehr snappy an, muss man sagen
Also Resizen geht
Frage ist
Wie kann ich das maximisen?
Geht das irgendwie?
Weil ohne ein Panel maximisen zu können
finde ich...
Oh.
Mein ZSH ist abgekackt hier drin.
Das ist merkwürdig.
Open Command Palette.
Ctrl-Shift-P.
Alter.
Gibt es sowas wie Zoom?
Maximize?
Nee.
Nextblitz kann das nicht, oder?
Expand? Gab es da sowas?
Ne, ne.
Maximize Split.
Does Northcote have a
Maximize Zoom Paint Toggle Action
to make a...
Okay.
Gibt es nicht.
Ne, Maus-Copy-Ding geht auch nicht zu konfigurieren.
Ne.
Ja, okay, ne.
Ganz ehrlich, da ist mir...
Es fühlt sich sehr snappy an.
Ja.
Kann man die Schriftgröße per Pane einstellen?
Ne, ich glaube, das ist komplett...
Ah ja, tatsächlich.
Okay, das ist ein cooles Feature.
Das ist ein cooles Feature.
Schriftgröße per Pane.
Das ist okay.
Wir schauen jetzt mal hier kurz.
NV Top.
Okay, das ist zu.
Der Split ist abgekackt.
Wie mache ich das jetzt zu?
Yes.
Wie war das?
Ctrl-Shift-D.
NV-Top.
Schauen wir mal.
GPU-Rendering.
Im Prinzip ähnlich wie bei Westrom.
Der Output ist halt
GPU-Accelerated.
Ja, cooles Projekt, aber Vorteile für Versus Westerm sehe ich jetzt für mich nicht.
Es ist schneller.
Keine Ahnung.
Kann ich jetzt schlecht beurteilen.
Was aber auch daran liegt, dass ich selten durch die Geschwindigkeit des Text-Outputs meines Terminals mich limitiert fühle.
Vivo Active 6, warum ausgerechnet die?
Was hat dich davon überzeugt?
Die ist bestimmt preis-leistungsmäßig ganz gut.
Ja, viel Spaß.
Wie gesagt,
richtet dir auch gleich die Garmin Connect App ein.
Das ist sehr hilfreich.
Und wenn es dir nicht gefällt, schick es einfach wieder zurück.
Aber schön, wenn ich dich in irgendeiner Art und Weise motiviert habe.
Moment.
Firefox macht
Raid Shadow Legends Werbung?
Was ist mit denen kaputt?
So, dann schauen wir doch mal, was Trend ist.
Okay, immerhin, Leute, wir haben heute
legit ein interessantes Projekt gefunden.
Bei den Trends.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Vielleicht finden wir ja noch mehr.
Welche ich hab?
Ich hab ne Garmin Forerunner
255S
Das ist aber nicht mal das aktuelle Modell
Ich hab mir damals gekauft
Weil das
Ähm, was soll ich sagen
Ich hab mich damals gekauft
Weil das halt ein gutes Einstiegsmodell ist
Alle Features hatte
Und halt lange Akkulaufzeiten
sowas.
Tatsächlich.
Raid Shadow Legends.
Ich fass es nicht.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie die Akku-Laufzeit
bei deiner ist. Deine ist deutlich günstiger.
Also auf jeden Fall, wenn du noch nicht genau
weißt, ist deine Wahl zum Einstieg
besser.
Raid Shadow Legends, Firefox, Alter.
Deutsche
Otto, LAN.
Amazon
Ah ne, das ist Plarium
Ah, Moment, Plarium?
Raid Shadow Legends? Ja, was denn? Ist das der Hersteller oder was?
Wait, ich habe immer noch meinen
Hetzer-Link drinne
WTF, Alter! Sponsoring 2021
Sollte ich vielleicht auch mal rausnehmen
So, Westterm
Westterm bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, wie viel Hertz ich eingestellt habe
Also ich habe hier 240
sich das, ne? Wie sieht man das
unter Wayland?
X-Render gibt's ja nicht mehr. Gibt's
W-Render?
X-Render Wayland.
WLR. WLR
Render. Okay. Ah, ne, Moment. Ich hab ja KDE.
Da kann ich einfach hier gucken.
Display Configuration.
Ne, ich will wissen, ob
mein... Hier, guck. Ich wollte sagen,
Monitor ist 240 Hertz.
excellent 42 herz western habe ich glaube ich auf 60 eingestellt fps welche fps
muss man da setzen animation fps oder gibt es wirklich ein fps ein wirklich
fps western fps config max fps guter ich finde es ein guter namen für eine
Option, oder? Findet ihr nicht auch?
He falls to 60.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Max FPS to falls
to 120.
Schauen wir mal zu.
So, jetzt ist die
Preisfrage. Fühlt sich das jetzt in irgendeiner
Art und Weise snappy-iger an?
Mit
Guck mal, NVD macht jetzt mehr GPU-Auslastung.
Näh.
War genauso.
Okay, Leute.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig, ob ich den Unterschied
zwischen 60 und 120 FPS im Terminal
spüre.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich spüre den Unterschied nicht.
Null.
Null spüre ich den Unterschied.
Absolut kein Unterschied. Aber macht ja nichts.
Mehr FPS sind immer besser.
Ich deinstalliere mal
und DaVinci Resolve. Das brauche ich ja immer drauf.
Das Max FPS greift unter Wayland nicht.
Geil.
Wayland, ignore.
Instead uses information
from the compositor to schedule.
Okay, compositor sagt
240. Also hatte ich die ganze
Zeit schon 240. Ich habe hier
irgendwas installiert. Was war das eben?
DaVinci Resolve. David,
Was habe ich da installiert?
Was ist das?
David
AV1-Crosp
Ah, ein AV1-Decoder
Ach, verstehe
AV1
Die Benamung wird immer sixheadiger
Bei Competitive Terminal
Ja, das stimmt
Competitive Terminal kann man aber auch nicht spielen
Über Capture Card
Gecaptured des Linux
Das geht nicht
Das muss native sein.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier für schöne Sachen?
Miese.
Ist das nicht ein Package-Manager gewesen eigentlich?
Bilde ich mir ein, wo man so Sachen wie Node.js und so installieren konnte?
Aube.
Es gibt auch die Excel-Weltmeisterschaft.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt nicht glaubt...
Excel World Championship.
Das hat die Excel-Weltmeisterschaft geschlossen.
Was für eine tolle Semifinals, die wir gerade hatten, oder?
Heute Abend sind die Top 12 Excel-E-Sportspieler in der ganzen Welt...
Also, das ist kein Witz. Ich habe euch... Das gibt es wirklich.
... auf dieser Stelle hier in der ikonischen HyperX Arena in Las Vegas,
bereit zu kämpfen durch einen der schwersten Fälle, die er kreiert.
Um mit Präzision und Strategie zu kämpfen.
Jede Zelle!
Wir sind alle auf der letzten Bühne heute Abend.
Michael Jarman mit seinem Lambda-Schein.
Er ist da drin.
Lambda-Kontrollen.
Das könnte für ein Orgami-Folding in Handy kommen.
Das stimmt.
Wenn wir jetzt kein Lambda-Folding haben,
werden sie nach diesem Fall was machen.
Das ist sicher.
Guck dir diese riesige Schale an Papier an,
die unsere Spieler durcharbeiten müssen,
um voll zu machen.
Das stimmt.
Das sind die Microsoft Excel World Championships 2025 gewesen.
Und hier hat er gewonnen
Das ist der Microsoft Excel Champion
Also ich habe euch da kein Mist erzählt
Es gibt tatsächlich Excel, Competitive, Excel
Und wo wir gerade schon bei Excel sind
Es gibt auch verrückte Leute, die haben Excel
Raytracing
programmiert.
Ist aber schon 6 Jahre her.
Excel Raytracing.
Keine Ahnung, wer Lotte ist.
Also die Leute wollen es echt wissen in Excel.
Das kann bestimmt sogar Doom runnen.
Oh.
Lotte von 0 zu 21 in 21 Sekunden.
Aha.
Die Empfehlungen sind auch wieder wild.
Postgres 19.
Next major upgrade.
Exzellent. Ja, Postgres
ist jetzt noch besser für
KI-Kram.
Das war auch wild. Kann ich mich trauen, das anzuklicken?
3D-Game-Engine in Factorio.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal gesehen.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich. Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Genau, in Factorio.
abgedreht. Die sind alle komplett durch.
Ich habe es euch vorgestellt, aber es erlaubt uns auch, die Perspektive zu verändern.
Also könnt ihr springen oder probieren.
Das ist das größte Erlebnis meines Lebens heute.
32-Bit-Computer in Terraria.
Ich habe es euch vorgestellt, dass ich es mit dem Computer verwendet habe.
Und jetzt...
Ah doch, jetzt wo ich das sehe, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das habe ich schon gesehen.
Das ist halt komplett abgedreht.
Also manche Leute sind wirklich hart drauf
Der Held am Freitag
Das habe ich doch vorhin schon geguckt
Ein bisschen, während ich gefrühstückt habe
Keine Ahnung, warum mir das empfohlen wird
Das habe ich vorhin sogar schon ein bisschen geguckt
Da hab ich das nicht vorhin schon geguckt
Irgendwie
Ja hab ich doch
Hab ich vorhin, vorhin wär ich nicht gefrühstückt
Da hab ich das schon geguckt
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich den Held hier gerade
Sitzen sehe in Frankfurt an diesen Bäumen
Leute
Setzt euch da nicht hin
In Frankfurt gibt es auf diesen Bäumen
Und drumherum so viele Tauben
Die da runter scheißen
Ich hab's schon mal geschafft, mich hier drunter zu setzen und vollgeschissen zu werden.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Das ist gefährlich, was er da zeigt.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir doch mal kurz durch, was trendet.
Also Rio. Rio war tatsächlich mal ein richtig interessantes Projekt.
Warum ich Western damit ablöse...
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Gitter Western.
Gibt es davon eigentlich mittlerweile mal eine neue Stable-Version?
Es wird ja echt immer Zeit.
Die ist von 2024 oder so, die letzte Stable-Version.
Ja, 2024.
Und es ist ja nicht so, als würde da nichts entwickelt, gell?
Die sind hier...
Guck mal, die sind permanent am entwickeln hier von Westerm.
Da geht's voll ab.
Also da gibt's jeden Tag...
Gibt es da Comets?
Fast.
Es wäre halt sinnvoll, da mal ein neues Release zu machen.
Next Release Checklist.
Ja, geil, von 2024.
Excellent.
Da traut sich keiner, einen Release zu machen, ja.
Ja, dann verwende ich, dann verwende ich.
Es ist immer ein bisschen schade, wenn es so keine Releases gibt, weil ich finde, das nimmt,
das nimmt vielen Leuten so die Lust drauf, die Software zu verwenden, ja.
Die kann noch so geil sein, die Leute wollen immer keine Unstable-Git-Versionen verwenden,
gerade wenn du den Kram dann auch selbst kompilen musst oder so.
Ja, dann gibt es immer keine offiziellen Packages, sondern nur Our-Packages.
und so ab und zu mal ein Release
ist schon echt ganz sinnig.
So, aber was trennt er denn hier sonst noch? Miese, hatten wir schon.
Ripgrab kennen wir auch.
Palkor DB.
Craft, okay, KI.
Komodo.
Ah ja,
das ist so ein Docker-Frontend
im Endeffekt.
Ein bisschen sowas wie DocPloy, nur
glaube ich leicht anderer Schwerpunkt.
Ein bisschen sowas wie
DocPloy ist das im Endeffekt.
Es gab doch früher auch mal...
Warte mal, Komodo, war das nicht auch...
Zertifikats...
Ach, Komodo, aber mit K schreibt man die, okay.
Und es gab früher auch mal eine Komodo IDE, gell?
Das gab es auch mal.
Aber von 2000, das ist uralt.
Aktuelle Version, Februar 2020.
komo du ide.com
Page not found. Jawohl. Nice.
Ist ja voll angesagt noch.
Wieso ich nicht ab und zu einen Release vom Fiat Champ bringe?
Brauche ich nicht. Brauche ich nicht.
Es gibt jetzt nämlich jemand.
Ich sollte das Projekt unbedingt mal auf
Archived setzen.
Not found.
Not found. Cannot be installed.
genau es hat jetzt jemand
nach homos ist integration programmiert dafür das heißt ich komme auch aktiv
am entwickeln das heißt ich muss den vier champ auch gar nicht mehr weiterentwickeln
Easy.
4M Champ.
4M Champ war vom Ansatz her nicht clever.
Ich hätte es anders machen müssen.
Nicht auf FlipWirt basieren, sondern direkt auf
Kuemu.
Aber ihr kennt mich doch.
Meine Projekte, da bin ich immer super motiviert
und irgendwann benutze ich es selbst
nicht mehr und dann habe ich keinen Bock mehr.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zu bieten?
Warpgate.
Fully transparent.
Also, Waldhorn.
Tokio.
Für die ganzen Rust-Stelzers unter uns.
Tokio ist...
der Default-Way, also nicht Default,
der Default-igste Way, den es unter Rust gibt,
Async-Sachen zu machen.
Deswegen habe ich auch in meinem Rust-Template für Rust-Projekte,
deswegen habe ich da auch standardmäßig
Poké-Mit drin.
rising wave hat klonen mit syntax highlighting hatten wir schon
great book from markdown falls a code review mit mit wim findings but why
jetzt hier
Okay, da muss ich ehrlich sagen
Ich bin ja ein Fan von Terminals
Sachen im Terminal machen
Aber für sowas
Ist manchmal ein Browser gar nicht verkehrt
Ulrich Quest aufmachen, Sachen durchscrollen, was zu schreiben
Also ich würde fast sagen
so vielleicht ist ein browser gar nicht verkehrt dafür sie leitungen emails was
man kann auch seiner wird verwendet ist ja nicht es ist ja nicht so dass man
sagen muss die anwendung haben überhaupt keinen sinn
sie leid geht dafür nämlich nur kit command line sonst nix also gui
Programme haben ja durchaus ihre Berechtigung teilweise. Flash Player Emulator. WTF?
Z-Agent Browser. Rust SDK.
Check if email exists. Wie macht das das? Wie macht das das? Check if an email address exists
without sending any email written in rust.
Und wie macht's das?
Okay.
Check email.
Run example.
Achso, login. Na geil.
Ja, wie macht's das? Wie kannst du das checken?
Tut das so oder was?
Baut das eine Verbindung zu einem E-Mail-Server auf und wartet auf einen Hello, ob es das gibt oder wie oder was?
Was ist denn das? Verify? What?
Ne, nicht Verify. Verify?
Ne, das wäre was anderes.
Achso, ist der cool.
E-Mail.
Ah.
Aha.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das gibt.
Das heißt, man kann vom Spam-Verschicken testen, ob der auch ankommt.
Servo. Gut.
Rust-Browser stellt's.
So, was für eine Sprache.
Chat, zwei Sprachen gucken wir noch.
Habt ihr einen Wunsch, wo wir uns Trends angucken?
Angucken wollen?
Eine suche ich aus, eine könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
C Sharp ist langweilig
PHP
C++
PHP haben wir schon lange nicht mehr geguckt
Weil es mich auch überhaupt nicht interessiert
PHP
Wir gucken jetzt PHP
Wir machen zwei Sprachen von euch
PHP
Lul, Alter
Chat, haben wir jemals PHP gemacht im Stream?
Ich glaube schon
Ich glaube, ich habe mal Laravel im Stream angeguckt
Und bin halt durchgedreht bei
Wobei ich in Laravel mal, als es recht neu war, was etwas umfangreiches gemacht habe,
ich habe mal so eine Stats-Seite gemacht, als ich noch einen Battlefield 4 Server hatte,
habe ich mit Laravel und PHP so eine Stats-Seite gemacht,
wo die Leute sehen können, wie viele Kills sie overall gemacht haben und sowas.
Elementor.
The most advanced frontend track and drop page builder.
Ne.
Absolut keine Ahnung.
News aggregator.
Customer relation management.
Für die keck Business Leute unter uns.
Aber keine Screenshots. Keine Screenshots ist immer schlecht.
das für die keck business menschen pest und geiler ist geiler name testing framework
ok wie wie hübsch sehen tests in php aus zeigt mal her ok schon mal kein
example ist auch immer geil test php ist guter name es gibt es okay es gibt es gibt keine
gering start es gibt keine code code examples ist nicht gibt es nicht examples gibt es gibt
es gibt es einfach nicht wisst ihr so seiten triggern mich immer richtig wie sagt wtf schreibt
halt einfach drei zeilen example drei zeilen example sagen mehr als 1000 bla bla auch kein
examples ordner dann hat nicht libre nms das ist für unsere ganzen netzwerk admins da war
ein beispiel wo war dann ein beispiel wo hier ist kein beispiel und hier ist auch kein beispiel
ach doch
ok ok gibt doch beispiele
ok ich habe nichts gesagt es erinnert mich ein bisschen an er speck in ruby
Kennt jemand...
Ich meine, Ruby ist nicht mal angesagt.
Aber hatte jemand mal das Vergnügen,
AirSpec zu verwenden in Ruby?
Ich fand das sehr angenehm früher.
AirSpec, Ruby.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das überhaupt noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise
angesagt ist, ja?
AirSpec, GitHub.
Warum ist Ruby nicht mal angesagt?
Weil Ruby on Rails nicht mehr angesagt ist.
Und ansonsten...
Ruby, die Sprache an sich
ist eines meiner Lieblingssprachen.
Aber so richtig,
das so richtig durchgesetzt hat sich das damals
mit Ruby on Rails und mit dem Abstieg von Ruby on Rails
war halt Ruby selbst nicht mehr angesagt.
Wobei ich Ruby als Sprache mag.
Ja.
Ich wollte nur gucken, wann es hier...
Okay, vor drei Monaten.
Aber Aspect fand ich halt schon nice.
Hast du sowas hier? Genau.
Aspect, Describe, Call, Add,
It returns, und bababab.
Das fand ich echt ganz gut.
Aber es ist schade, dass Ruby...
Also,
ich, wenn ich mir was wünschen dürfte
in dieser Richtung, ja,
wäre mir lieber, Ruby hätte sich durchgesetzt
versus Python
für das ganze Zeug, wo es heute verwendet wird.
Für mich ist Ruby die viel schönere und elegantere Sprache.
Aber Python hat ja anscheinend zu der richtigen Zeit auf die richtigen Sachen gesetzt.
Ging los mit ganzen Machine Learning Sachen, jetzt KI Geschichten, irgendwelche Prototype Web Geschichten und alles.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sich Python mehr durchgesetzt hat als Ruby.
Wahrscheinlich waren die einfach zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort mit den richtigen Libraries und Frameworks.
So, Laravel trendet.
Wahrscheinlich das einzige PHP-Framework, was es erträglich macht, eine Web-Anwendung zu programmieren.
Kimi, nee, Kim AI is Open Source Time Tracking Application.
Aha, Panel.
Gameserver-Panel.
Wut.
Wutz.
Da hat einer mit FFM-Pack
einen GIF gemacht und sich
nicht angeguckt, wie man ordentlich mit FFM-Pack
GIFs macht. Dann kommt nämlich sowas dabei raus.
Man kann mit FFM-Packer
ordentliche GIFs machen.
Ich weiß...
PIM, MDM,
CDP, DAM,
DXP, CMS...
What the fuck?
Was?
W-W-C-M-S?
Ich hab...
Ich hab das jetzt alles gelesen, hab absolut keine Ahnung, was das überhaupt sein soll.
Product Experience Management.
Was?
PXM.
Ey, kein Plassenschimmer, was das überhaupt sein soll.
Das sieht oldschool aus.
Aber was hat das mit Mobile Device Management zu tun?
Open Source Repos.
Ne, nicht Repos, POS.
Point of Sale.
Shopware, Symfony, Snipet.
Das habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, hat sich bei mir nicht durchgesetzt.
Das ist so ein Inventar-Management-System für Hardware-Sachen.
PrestaShop.
Unglaublich, wie viele Shopping-Systeme
irgendwie auf PHP basieren.
Was dann wahrscheinlich einfach daran liegt, dass es das schon uralt gibt.
Und, das ist auch ein großer Faktor,
dass PHP halt auf jedem
Billighoster läuft.
Das hat sich jetzt nicht so richtig gelohnt.
Was ich aber witzig finde,
das PHP-Ökosystem hat sich eigentlich
in den letzten 15 Jahren nicht geändert.
Ist immer noch
irgendeine wilde Mischung aus CMS und
Shop-Software.
So, Chat, was wollt ihr
sonst noch haben?
C++?
Ja, Java.
Julia. Hab ich noch nie
verwendet.
Erlang.
Nee.
Komm, wir machen mal.
Komm, wir machen jetzt Java.
Mit Native PHP kannst du nun sogar
PHP auf iPhone, Android laufen
Gott sei Dank, das habe ich gebraucht
Pearl, wir gucken, Leute, Leute
Scheiß auf Java, wir gucken Pearl
Okay, da trendet tatsächlich
nur was
Clock
Count Plank Lines
Einfach 23.000
Flamecraft
Das sind diese Dinger, genau, die aussehen wie 1995
Und auch wahrscheinlich von 1995 stammen
Exif Cleaner
Moment, eine
Eine Cross-Plattform
Desktop-GUI-App
in Perl.
Wie macht man denn
Cross-Plattform-Desktop in Perl?
WTF?
Keine Ahnung.
Source?
Äh, ja.
Renderer vielleicht?
Äh, Moment.
Elektron?
ist es
JavaScript? Stell's.
Perl und TypeScript.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, worauf das
basiert. Wir fragen mal.
Wir fragen mal ChatGPT.
Auf welcher
GUI-Technik
basiert
Elektron 25.
Okay, nice. Alles klar.
Moment, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Der hat einen Pearl Backend und eine Elektron-Anwendung.
Und die Elektron-Anwendung redet mit dem Pearl Backend.
Das ist ja voll durch die Brust ins Auge.
Weil du hast bei Elektron ja ein vollständiges Node.js dabei für solche Sachen.
Krasser.
Alter, ist das abgedreht.
Das ist glaube ich eines der ausgefallensten Software-Stacks für eine Anwendung, die ich je gesehen habe.
Pearl Weekly Challenges.
Guck mal, bei Pearl kommst du in die Trends mit 0 Sternen die Woche.
LM Sensors.
LM Sensors benutze ich öfters.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das in Pearl programmiert ist.
KI-Zeug.
Wobei, das ist Pearl.
Wahrscheinlich ist das gar nicht KI.
Guilty Agent.
Perl 5.
Ganze zwei
zwei
Sterne hatte ich sprach die Woche.
Wer ist eigentlich der Perl-Erfinder?
Ach, der. Der da.
Okay, ja.
Okay, Perl war jetzt wirklich nicht.
Da muss ich jetzt doch nochmal Ja verkaufen.
Okay, komm. Für die Julia-Fans
im Chat.
Ich hab noch nie was mit Julia gemacht.
Geschweige denn, mir irgendwie großartig was angeguckt.
Was trendet denn da so?
Die Programmiersprache an selbst.
Die hatte, glaube ich, eine ganz angenehme Syntax, was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Aber ich wüsste halt nicht, wofür ich die jetzt benutzen würde.
Examples vielleicht ist das.
Naja, ob das eine angenehme Syntax ist, kann man sich jetzt sicherlich drüber streiten.
Klimaatmos.
GPU capable global
atmosphere. Okay, das ist hier für irgendwelche
Quickmuffs, Leute.
Physics und
und Mathe und sowas.
Okay.
Komm, dann gucken wir zum Schluss doch nochmal,
was in Java so trendet.
Da irgendwas Spannendes.
Google Core Libraries for Java. Juckt mich nicht.
DB.
DBiver.
Das habe ich tatsächlich irgendwann schon mal benutzt.
Vor längerer Zeit.
Ich glaube sogar im Stream.
Weil da habe ich gefragt, kennt jemand ein gutes DB-Management-Tool?
Da hat, glaube ich, jemand DB-Biver geschrieben.
Hat man das, glaube ich, ausprobiert.
Basil.
Copiler SDK.
Gidra.
Für die Hackermans. Für die reverse-engineerenden Hackermans. Spring, Java selbst. Nee, Algorithms in Java. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Network Monitor für Android, okay.
Liquibase, da haben wir auf der Arbeit eine Anwendung, die benutzt Liquibase und das macht richtige Probleme,
weil Liquibase wohl irgendwie keine klassische SQL-Datenbank ist, die man mit irgendwelchen Command-Line-Tools gescheit reingucken kann,
sondern Liquid-Basing so ein eigenes Format ist
und wenn da ein Error drin ist
oder irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert,
kannst du das nicht gescheit debuggen.
Das ist weird,
aber das ist bestimmt Skill-Issue,
weil ich einfach zu dumm für bin.
Maven,
Bildstelz,
Trino,
Distributed SQL Query Engine
von Big Data,
Foldcraft Launcher,
Minecraft, Neo4j,
Ah.
Termux.
Das habe ich auch oft benutzt unter Android,
auf Android-Tablets.
Ich hatte nie ein Android-Telefon.
Android-Tablets hatte ich ein paar. Habe ich auch immer noch
im Flur hängen als Dashboards.
Für Daily-Use-Tablets
nur iPads. Ich finde,
das ist not even close. Die Dinger sind einfach
viel besser für tägliches
Benutzen. Bei Android und iPhones
bei Telefonen kann man sich da
bestimmt noch drüber streiten, aber ich finde, bei Tablets
ist Apple echt mal ein weit vorne.
Aber für so
Sachen, wo man viel automatisieren
will, so als Dashboard-Anzeige und so,
sind Android-Tablets gut.
Die sind günstig und kannst halt alles dran einstellen.
Macht
Liquibase nicht Datenbank-Versionierung?
Vielleicht bringe ich es auch durcheinander.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht meine ich auch was anderes.
Okay, dann ist es
doch was anderes.
Dann meinte ich nicht das.
Wie heißt das? Es gibt so eine
Datenbank. So quasi,
es gibt so eine Art
Java SQLite, nenne ich es mal.
Also wo du mit Java,
das könnte sogar Standard Library sein, ich weiß es nicht.
Da kannst du mit Java quasi
so Datenbank-Sachen anlegen, ohne
dass du halt ein externes Datenbank-Dependency
hast auf irgendwie Postgres oder so.
H2,
das kann sein. Das ist
möglich. Ja, das kann sein.
kommt mir bekannt vor
Paper
Minecraft Server
Spring Boot
das haben wir auch schon im Stream gemacht
Spring Boot haben wir auch schon gestreamt
ok und jetzt zum Abschluss einfach random
random random random
ich mach die Augen zu random random random
Jason 0
Gibt es Training-Repos in JSON?
Okay, gibt es.
Drei Stück.
Ziemlich unsinnig.
Düdüdü.
Chat, ich fand den Stream gestern so nice,
dass ich mir YouTube-Videos
angeguckt habe, zu Typer
für
Python Command Line Apps
und zu
FastAPI.
Falls ich da noch ein bisschen mit rumspielen
will.
Das ist jetzt halt so mein typischer Basteltrang,
weil es was Neues ist und mich interessiert.
Ich gehe davon aus, ich werde
wahrscheinlich nie größere
Python-Anwendungen bauen.
Auch wenn ich jetzt weiß, wie man
die schön distributed als single self-contained anwendung wahrscheinlich werde ich nie benutzen
ja was macht hyper das ist für command line apps da kannst du das ist so was wie die spektakon
soll zum ähnlich spektakon soll spektakon online oder system command line du kannst damit weil ich
zeig dir einfach ganz damit kommandozeilen anwendung so deklarativ mit mit annotations
und so anlegen.
Guck.
So wie das hier.
App gleich Typer
und dann kannst du hier App Command
Hello und dann erstellt er dir
automatisch
eine Anwendung, wo du minus minus help
machen kannst, dann zeigt er dir die Commands an.
Wenn du Anwendung ausführst
mit einem Argument Hello,
dann geht er automatisch hier rein.
Das ist so ein Command Line App Framework.
So quasi Command Line Parser
und um das ein bisschen schöner zu strukturieren.
Fand ich eigentlich ganz nice
Was ich für .NET eine Zeit lang ganz gut
Fand war, Kokona
Aber das wird glaube ich nicht mehr weiterentwickelt
Und mittlerweile gibt es da auch, glaube ich
Standard Library Alternativen
Ja, wurde archivt
Das fand ich aber ein schönes Framework
Mal eine Zeit lang für .NET
da konntest du nämlich auch so dinger machen wie hier guckt da konnte nämlich einfach sagen hier
ab rand string name und dann hat es automatisch eine command line parameter daraus generiert mit
dem namen name und sowas das war eigentlich ziemlich cool mittlerweile gibt es das nicht
mehr mittlerweile ist das archiv aber ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile ganz gute standard library
Sachen dafür.
Aber damals gab es das noch nicht.
Hintergrundmusik?
Ja, Hintergrundmusik
brauche ich immer.
Machen wir mal kurz.
Ja.
Exzellent.
sehr schön ich lasse es mal offen
so was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an
als kriege ich hier für dinge wieder empfohlen
so was haben wir das können wir uns jetzt mal zusammen auf youtube angucken aber irgendwas
Spannendes. BMW bringt
jetzt Werbung ins Cockpit. Okay, das guckt man sein.
Da kann ich mich selbst
Rage baiten.
Self-Rage bait.
Er kauft ein Auto für 70.000
oder sogar 80.000 Euro.
War das bei BMW nicht so, dass die
Sitzheizung standardmäßig eingebaut ist,
aber nur per Software
Abo freigeschaltet werden kann?
Das ist auch echt so krass mittlerweile.
Alter.
Gibt es da irgendwelche Custom-Firmware-Hacks,
um das zu unlocken ohne Abo?
Das lassen sich die Leute doch nicht zweimal sagen.
Also ich habe letztens auf XDA, glaube ich,
einen Post gefunden.
Da hat einer
einen
Jailbreak des Uconnect hochgeladen, was man auf seinen Fiat flashen kann.
Ich habe mich dann aber dagegen entschieden, das zu machen.
Er steigt ein und es erscheint Werbung auf dem Display.
Nicht für ein neues BMW-Modell, sondern für einen Kinofilm.
Great Shadow Legends.
Genau darüber diskutieren BMW-Fahrer und das Netz gerade weltweit.
Beim Start ihres Autos werden sie von Spider-Man begrüßt.
Das Ganze ist eine offizielle Aktion von BMW und Sony Pictures.
Die einen finden das völlig harmlos, manche sogar sehr lustig.
Die anderen sagen, damit ist eine rote Linie überschritten.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Schauen wir uns an, was genau passiert ist und warum es dabei um viel mehr geht, als nur um einen Superhelden.
BMW kooperiert mit Sony Pictures für den neuen Film Spider-Man Brand New Day, der im August in die Kinos kommt.
Und diese Kooperation hat es tatsächlich bis ins Auto geschafft.
Beim Starten des Fahrzeugs erscheint auf dem zentralen Display ein Banner.
Tippt man darauf, startet eine Vollbildanimation mit Spider-Man, begleitet von passender Musik.
Sogar die Ambientebeleuchtung des Fahrzeugs wird in die Inszenierung eingebunden.
Betroffen sind praktisch alle BMW mit den Betriebssystemen Operating System 7, 8, 8.5, 9 und 10.
Okay, ich find's geil, dass BMW das Ding einfach Operating System nennt.
Einfach so ganz trocken.
Wie soll man den Kram nennen, was auf unseren Bordcomputern läuft?
Operating System.
Und OSX, die seit Juli 2020 gebaut wurden.
BMW rollt die Aktion nach eigenen Angaben in mehr als 70 Ländern aus.
BMW selbst bezeichnet das Ganze übrigens nicht als Werbung.
Offiziell spricht der Hersteller von einer besonderen Überraschung für seine Kundinnen und Kunden.
Die Animation ist dieselbe Funktion, über die BMW bislang Weihnachts-, Halloween-
oder neujahrsanimationen verteilt hat ausgeliefert der entscheidende unterschied ist allerdings früher
ging es um bmw selbst jetzt wird bmw erstmals für einen externen partner eigentlich geht es deshalb
gar nicht um spider man die eigentliche frage lautet darf ein autohersteller nach dem verkauf
werbeinhalte auf dem display eines autos anzeigen moderne fahrzeuge sind ja heute permanent mit dem
internet verbunden genau deshalb du hast garantiert beim ersten start irgendwelche
toss abgehakt dass die das dürfen können hersteller neue funktionen ausrollen karten
material aktualisieren oder software fehler bequem per update beheben das ist einer der
großen vorteile moderne autos aber dieselbe technik ermöglicht eben auch etwas anderes
hersteller können nach dem kauf jederzeit neue inhalte auf millionen fahrzeuge bringen und genau
Genau hier beginnt für viele Fahrer das Unbehagen. Denn wenn heute ein Kinofilm beworben wird, was kommt dann morgen?
Ein Streamingdienst? Eine Versicherung? Ein Reifenhersteller?
Pornhub?
Oder irgendwann personalisierte Angebote, abhängig davon, wohin ich fahre oder vielleicht sogar wie?
Das wäre bestimmt der Renner bei den BMW-Fahrern.
Genau diese Sorge liest man derzeit in vielen Diskussionen.
Besonders interessant ist dabei ein Detail.
Verantwortlich für die Aktion ist BMW-Manager Stefan Durach, Senior Vice President Connected Company Development.
Alter, der hat ja mal einen krassen Titel.
Und genau der ist BMW-Manager Stefan Durach, Senior Vice President Connected Company Development.
Das ist so lang, dass ich es mir nicht mal merken kann. Senior Vice President Connected... was? Development? What the fuck?
Der Titel ist so lang, dass man sich den nicht mal merken kann.
ist BMW-Manager Stefan Durach, Senior Vice President Connected Company Development.
Und erlaubt, dieser Manager sagte Ende 2023 in einem Interview mit der Werbefachpublikation Media Post sinngemäß etwas völlig anderes.
Damals erklärte er, das Auto sei der letzte private Rückzugsraum.
Ja, aber das ist ja nun wirklich nichts Neues.
Vor allem in der aktuellen Zeit nichts Neues.
Dass da irgendwie einer heute was sagt und morgen was anderes macht.
Der Merz macht's uns vor.
Menschen heute noch hätten.
Genau deshalb...
Du konntest ja auch gerade noch nie was drauf geben, wenn die heute was gesagt haben.
...wolle BMW dort keine Werbung verkaufen.
Knapp drei Jahre später erscheint nun ausgerechnet im Cockpit Werbung für einen Kinofilm.
Genau deshalb wird dieses alte Interview derzeit in den sozialen Netzwerken immer wieder zitiert.
Viele sehen darin außerdem keinen Einzelfall.
BMW sorgte bereits vor einigen Jahren für heftige Diskussionen, als Funktionen wie die Sitzheizung zeitweise per Abo freigeschaltet werden sollten, obwohl die Hardware bereits im Auto verbaut war.
Das Modell wurde später wieder eingestellt.
Jetzt geht es zwar nicht ums Bezahlen, aber erneut stellt sich dieselbe Grundsatzfrage.
Welche Rechte behält ein Hersteller eigentlich an ein Produkt, nachdem es verkauft wurde?
Ist das Auto wirklich vollständig Eigentum des Käufers oder bleibt das Display dauerhaft eine Kommunikationsfläche des Herstellers?
fairerweise muss man aber auch sagen nicht jeder bmw fahrer regt sich darüber auf auch bei uns
im heise forum gibt es zahlreiche stimmen die sagen das banner erscheint das heise forum ist
auch so ein spezieller ort einmal beim start ich wette mit ihr das mindestens ich wette mit euch
dass mindestens einer darunter geschrieben hat in die kommentare im heise forum mit linux wäre
das nicht passiert man tippt es weg nach drei sekunden ist alles vorbei und wie gesagt viele
finden es sogar lustig. Für diese Fahrer ist die eigentliche Animation kein Problem. Die Diskussion
dreht sich deshalb weniger um Spider-Man selbst als um den Präzedenzfall. Denn wenn Werbung heute
akzeptiert wird, könnte sie morgen deutlich häufiger auftauchen. Und genau das macht viele
skeptisch. Und genau das ist die spannende Frage. Nicht ob Spider-Man hübsch animiert ist, sondern
ob wir akzeptieren wollen, dass Hersteller nach dem Kauf eines Autos Werbeinhalte auf dessen Display
platzieren. Heute ist es ein Kinofilm,
morgen vielleicht ganz was anderes.
Uns interessiert deshalb eure Meinung.
Ist das für euch völlig harmlos, weil die Animation
nach wenigen Sekunden verschwindet?
Oder sagt ihr, in einem Auto, das ich
gekauft habe, hat Werbung nichts verloren?
Ja, das sage ich.
Schreibt es unten in die Kommentare.
Was würde ich dagegen machen?
Könnte ich aber auch nicht.
Wenn ich so ein Auto hätte.
Aber ich sehe das genauso.
Ich finde, das hat da nichts verloren.
Würde mich besonders interessieren, habt ihr die
Spider-Man-Animationen bereits gesehen und
wie hat sie auf euch gewirkt?
Ja, und wenn das Video interessant war, gerne ein Like
geben, mit einem Abo verpasst ihr nichts hier.
Mehr News gibt es auf heise.de
Ja, und apropos Werbung, dazu... Erstmal Custom,
erstmal Custom-Firmware. Noch rasch was in eigener
Sache, denn wenn ihr gerne tiefer
in IT- und Technikthemen einsteigt,
schaut doch auch mal auf heise plus
vorbei. Dort gibt es Hintergründe...
Ich hatte mal ein heise plus Abo.
und
ich wollte das wieder kündigen
und das hat nicht richtig über die Webseite funktioniert
da musste ich da erst
eine E-Mail hinschreiben
dass das gekündigt wird
also
voll für den Arsch
ja am 12.
am 12. August
ist Sonnenfinsternis bei uns
Sonnenfinsternis ist ja in der Regel tagsüber
Also kann man gucken.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zu bieten?
The fastest way to store Bitcoins was just hacked.
Ah ja, Fire, Fire Ship.
Was hätten wir sonst noch?
BMW-Fahrer sind sauer, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Okay, was soll ich machen?
Wir gucken mal auf Fireship, Fireship macht doch auch immer
Gute Videos, auch wenn ich mir da nicht sicher bin
Ob die nicht mittlerweile komplett KI generiert sind
Ein Non-AI-Fireship-Video, das ist selten, ja
Die schlechte Nachricht ist, dass viele Menschen...
Bescheid, so.
Also, AF-Programmer,
ich weiß schon, dass du das als Witz
gemeint hast, ja, aber dieses Comment
hätte ich mir eins zu eins so vorstellen können,
auf irgendeinem passenden
Subreddit.
Das finde ich auch immer geil,
wenn es zum Thema Klimaerwärmung geht, da kommen
die Leute dann immer so mit um die Ecke, so
ja, früher war es
auch im Sommer warm, da kann ich mich noch
dran erinnern. Oder das Wetter hat sich schon immer geändert. Die Sonnenaktivität ist
Schuld oder irgendwie so Zeug. Alter, da kriegst du immer Kopfweh bei. Nachts ist es kälter
als draußen, genau. Okay, jetzt kommt mal mal Fire Ship.
Oh.
die euch leitungen über die Art und Weise, wie man nicht wirklich Freiheit verdient, wenn man seine Karten in den Austausch hat.
In diesem Video werden wir uns über die Art und Weise, wie ein Hack funktioniert und lernen,
warum die Verbrecher jetzt gegen die Verbrecher in der Realzeit beten.
Tonken Generator
und der hatte
einen Sensor darauf, der quasi aus
Rauschen
Random Zahlen erstellen kann.
Also quasi Zahlen, die sehr, die
super random sind. Also richtig
echt random. Nicht generiert random.
Und da gab es aber eine Firmware Bug,
dass das gar nicht benutzt wurde,
sondern irgendein billiger
Random Generator, der
anhand von der Uhrzeit oder so
gesiedet wurde und man deswegen ganz
einfach die Sachen durchprobieren kann und an die Tokens kommt. So habe ich das im Hinterkopf. Mal
gucken, ob das so ist.
Das ist viel.
Also das ist wirklich viel.
Gut, dann habe ich das ja wohl richtig im Kopf gehabt.
Ja gut, aber ganz ehrlich Leute, gegen MicroPython ist doch eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen.
Es gibt auch viele Projekte, die auf dem ESP32 zum Beispiel laufen mit MicroPython.
Ich habe es jetzt noch nicht benutzt für größere Sachen, aber warum nicht?
... nowhere strong enough for generating keys.
Coinkite knew this, so they wrote their own generator and by setting a specific flag to zero,
they disabled MicroPython's generator, or at least that's what they thought.
But here's where things went wrong.
Beide Nummergeneratoren haben eine Funktion mit dem selben Namen ausgesprochen.
Und die Krypto-Library würde entscheiden, welche zu nutzen, basierend auf einem, wenn nicht definierten, Check.
Und weil die Flagge technisch definiert wurde, nur als 0,
passierte der Check und jede Seed-Phrase wurde von der normalen MicroPython-Nummergenerator generiert.
Nicht der kaltkarte, sophisticated Generator.
Aber es scheint, weil ein bare-metal Chip kein Operationssystem hat,
gibt es nirgendwo, wo MicroPythons Nummergenerator auskommt, um echte Ungewöhnlichkeit zu bekommen.
Also faked er es statt, mit dem Seriennummer und einem Timer.
Beide sind entscheidend.
Also vor allem, das Ding bei sowas ist halt,
die Randomness ist ja nicht komplett weg.
Du hast die Seriennummer drin, du hast die Uhrzeit drin.
Das Problem ist nur, dass es eben die Range, die möglich ist, extrem einschränkt.
Du kannst es einfach durchprobieren.
Wenn man eine Seed-Phrase aus jedem Atom im Universum auswählen würde,
könnte man einfach alle möglichen Kombinationen von Seriennummern und Timer-Werte durchlaufen
und mit allen Kiefern wegkommen.
Und am 30. Juli, das ist genau das, was der Attacker gemacht hat.
In unter einer Stunde, der erste Attacker drang über 1.000 Bitcoin aus fast 1.200 Adressen,
schießt die größten Wallets zuerst.
Dann gab es zwei weitere Attacks über den Wochenende,
die den Total von fast 1.800 Bitcoin aus über 7.000 Adressen gedrängt haben.
Der CEO von Coinkite hat verabschiedet und hat volle Verantwortung genommen,
aber durch die Natur der...
Wir nehmen die ganze Verantwortung für den Firmware-Bug und ergeben unsere Entschuldigungen.
Sie konnten nicht nur eine Firmware-Update anbieten, um das Problem zu lösen.
Because Bitcoin has no way to rotate a key, the only way out is for victims to generate a brand new seed and move their coins with an actual on-chain transaction.
But of course, because this is Bitcoin, every transaction waits in the public mempool until a miner includes it in a block,
which means the attacker can just watch the mempool for anything coming from a compromised address.
They can then sign their own competing transaction with the same keys and a higher fee, and miners will confirm the highest bidder first.
So when a fourth attack went live on Monday morning, the only way to win was to skip the public mempool entirely and send your rescue transaction directly to a mining pool, since the bot can't outbid a transaction it never sees.
So yeah, the official rescue plan for your trustless decentralized money was to put all your trust in one centralized miner and hope for the best.
Wie bei Coinkite, hat jeder ungekaufte Gerät in ihrem Warehaus das selbe gebrochene Firmware mitgebracht,
also mussten sie die Schiffen aufhalten und den restlichen Inventar rausnehmen.
Aber all das hätte sie nur mit Lovable, dem Sponsor dieses Videos, gebraucht.
Das muss man sagen. Seine Transitions für Sponsoring sind immer gut.
Das hat er drauf.
Was ist das?
Hammer der Woche aus Wendlingen.
Wo ist denn Wendlingen?
In Wendlingen wurde ein Radweg gebaut.
Doch, also mein Radwege
habe ich mich jetzt auch schon öfters ausgekotzt,
sind in Deutschland im größten Teil voll für den Arsch.
Ich will jetzt nicht wieder anfangen von dem
Meinweg, den es bei uns, von dem
Radschnellweg, den es geben soll.
Nord- und Südmainisch.
Und der seit 15 Jahren
in der...
In welcher Phase ist der...
Irgendwie die dritte Machbarkeitsstudie
läuft und sowas.
Will ich jetzt gar nicht von anfangen.
Im Wendlingen am Neckar
in Baden-Württemberg hat das Land
diesen Damm erhöht.
Moment.
Ich muss das hier reinmachen, damit ich es ein bisschen lauter machen kann.
Ablehnen.
In Wendlingen am Neckar in Baden-Württemberg hat das Land diesen Damm erhöht mit einem schicken Radweg obendrauf.
Dumm nur, dass die...
Okay, ist halt so ein bisschen Gravel, aber da kannst du mit allen Rädern drauf fahren.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass du mit Rennrädern, dass du quasi sowas nur mit einem Gravel-Bike fahren kannst, der Blödsinn.
Die Dammkrone jetzt aber wegen der Erhöhung dieser alten Hochspannungsleitung gefährlich nahekommt.
Das hat man erst während der Bauarbeiten bemerkt. Bei der Planung wurde es vergessen.
Die Folge, der schöne neue Weg wird gespart. Hier.
Und dabei haben die doch bestimmt 15 Machbarkeitsstudien vorher durchgeführt.
Darf niemand mehr durch.
Das ist eine Fehlplanung. Also vernünftige, meist sogar studierte Leute, also die hätten...
Aber bisschen Scheiße kann immer passieren. Ganz ehrlich, ich finde es gar nicht schlimm, dass sowas passiert.
Ja, wenn das Einzelfälle sind und so, es kann immer mal Scheiße passieren. Das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass in Deutschland sich die nächsten 25 Jahre daran nichts ändern wird.
Das fixt keiner jetzt schnell. Das ist das Ding.
Das natürlich im Vorfeld merken müssen.
Für mich ist das gar nicht nachvollziehbar, wie das passieren kann. Die Leitung war ja vorher da. Ich muss ja bloß schon messen, wie hoch das Ding ist.
Und ich weiß den Abstand, wie weit ich von der Hochspannungsleitung weg sein muss mit meinem Fahrweg.
2020 beginnen die Bauarbeiten. Der bestehende Damm wird um 60 Zentimeter erhöht.
Guck mal, 2020, Alter. 2020. Die haben allen Ernstes fucking sechs Jahre gebraucht, um den Damm aufzuschütten.
Bei uns dauert alles so übertrieben lang.
Ich meine, wir müssen es nicht machen wie in China, wo jetzt drei Bauarbeiter im Damm verschüttet werden oder so.
Aber vielleicht auch nicht sechs Jahre für einen Damm aufschütten.
So ein Zwischending wäre doch ganz nice.
Das Bauprojekt. Im Frühjahr 2024 wären der Bauarbeiten dann die böse Überraschung.
Die neue Höhe des Dams verträgt sich nicht mit der Hochspannungsleitung.
Du arbeitest selbst in der Branche, das sind keine Einzelfälle.
Ja und woran liegt das? Ich meine, wir haben doch immer Machbarkeitsstudien und dann irgendwelche Leute, Sachverständige, die sich das ansehen.
Warum kommt das dann so oft vor?
Hat man vergessen, den Betreiber der Leitung im Planfeststellungsverfahren anzurühren.
Jetzt bestimmt Gefahr, dass Fahrzeuge der Hochspannungsleitung zu nahe kommen.
Deshalb wird der Weg für alle dicht gemacht.
Es lässt mich so langsam ein bisschen an das deutsche Ingenieurwesen zweifeln.
Da gibt es ja noch mehr Sachen.
Ich will eigentlich wissen, wenn schon 40 Jahre ein Stromkabel ist und das vorher betrachtet, wie man dann hochbauen kann.
Egal aus welchen Gründen, dass man das einfach beachtet. Ich verstehe nicht, dass man sowas übersehen kann.
Tatsächlich sind hier ja täglich Radfahrer unterwegs und auch größere Gruppen, die dann eben merken, hier geht es nicht weiter, ich muss wieder umdrehen.
Aber wie kann es passieren, dass man den Betreiber der Stromtrasse nicht anhört?
Das Regierungspräsidium Stuttgart teilt uns schriftlich mit.
Bei der Komplexität der zu Beteiligenden kann es leider versäumt werden, einen Beteiligten formal anzuhören.
Chad meint, das sind keine deutschen Ingenieure. Meinst du, deutschen Ingenieure könnte sowas nicht passieren?
Da habe ich meine Zweifel.
Wir nutzen den Radweg regelmäßig und wäre natürlich schön, wenn man den nutzen könnte, anstatt hier durchs Industriegebiet fahren zu müssen.
Ich werde an die Straße gezwungen, obwohl ich gerne auf diesem landschaftlich schöneren Weg fahren würde.
Einfach so umbauen geht nicht.
Und auf der Straße hast du dann das Problem, dass der 85-jährige Rentner denkt, obwohl du ziemlich ordentlich fährst, ja, also es ist ja so, du musst ja, wie viel? 50 Zentimeter? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Musst du beim Überholen Abstand halten und das ist so.
Moment, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal kurz. Nehmen wir mal hier einfach Maps, Google, Frankfurt oder so.
So.
Wenn wir da jetzt mal ranzoomen.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal irgendwas.
Irgendeine Straße in Frankfurt.
Vollkommen egal.
Das ist natürlich jetzt eine doofe Straße.
Irgendwas ohne Straßenbahn vielleicht.
Irgendwie random hier.
Wenn du jetzt...
1,5 Meter.
So viel ist das sogar.
Okay, das ist immer kein Plan.
müsste ich eigentlich aus zwei Gründen wissen,
dass ich mich...
Auto gegen Auto sind es 50 cm, okay.
Also einigen wir uns mal
auf mindestens 50 cm, okay?
Egal was das ist. So, jetzt ist halt
das Problem, wenn du jetzt
Fahrrad fährst, das ist jetzt nur mal exemplarisch,
ich meine das nicht explizit, die Straße. Ich brauche jetzt einfach nur ein Bild
von der Straße, okay? So.
Man neigt als Fahrradfahrer dazu,
das habe ich früher auch gemacht, man neigt dazu,
ganz eng hier
zu fahren, weil...
man ja nicht in Konflikt geraten will mit Autos.
Ja, guck hier, so.
Oder noch näher.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass sobald irgendwas ist,
hier, ja,
dass hier irgendwie einer nicht guckt,
einen Schritt auf die Straße macht,
oder dass hier ein Huppel ist,
oder ein Schlagloch oder so,
dass du nicht richtig ausweichen kannst,
im Zweifelsfall gegen den Bordstein fährst,
aufs Maulfels oder so,
oder vor das überholende Auto fährst,
weil es nicht genug Abstand hält. Das heißt, wenn du einfach selbst ein bisschen weiter, und das darfst du, das ist nicht so, dass du das nicht darfst, wenn du einfach selbst ein bisschen hier mittig fährst, das heißt, da können die dich einfach gar nicht random überholen, ohne zu gucken, dass alles frei ist.
Und dann hast du halt das Problem, wenn du hier fährst, auf der Straße, da darfst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht fahren, dann hast du dann wieder irgendwelche 75, 85-jährigen Rentner, die keine Zeit haben und dich gefährlich überholen.
überholen.
Ja, die überholen aber, das ist es ja,
die überholen aber, wenn du,
wenn du es erlaubst, ja.
Die überholen, weil
sie können überholen, wenn du ganz am Rand fährst.
Wenn du selbst einfach,
sagen wir mal nochmal, selbst 50 cm
Platz zum Rand lässt, dann können die nicht überholen.
Genau.
Das ist auch was, das musst du dich lernen.
Es ist je nach Straße
tatsächlich sinnvoll,
ein bisschen Platz zu lassen,
sodass die Autofahrer nicht auf doof Ideen kommen können.
Deswegen fahre ich auch sehr, sehr ungern auf Straßen, wo auch Autos fahren.
Das lässt sich nicht immer vermeiden, aber zu, ich sag mal, 95% nehme ich Wege, wo halt keine Autos fahren.
Ich kann das auch ganz gut.
Ich kann das auch ganz gut
Weil ich hab mir ja ein Gravelrad gekauft
Mit den passenden Reifen drauf und so
Also ich kann auch ohne Probleme
Ziemlich holprige Schotterwege fahren
Und
Irgendwelche
Waldwege und
Rampelfade und so, das geht ganz gut
Ja
Du kannst das in beschränktem Maße
Kannst du das mit einem
Rennrad für die Straße auch machen.
Allerdings nicht bis
zum gleichen Level.
Ein schöner, glatt gedrückter
Schotterweg. Oder kannst du
ein Stückchen fahren mit dem Rennrad. Ja, das ist kein Problem.
Aber das fühlt sich halt schon
auf asphaltierten Wegen deutlich besser.
Wieso fährst du wie ein Arsch?
Du fährst das, was es erlaubt.
Das ist vollkommen legit.
Auf dem Dorf gibt es die Probleme genauso.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir gucken können?
Irgendwas Spannendes?
Ah, hier geht es jetzt.
Es gibt immer zig verschiedene Firmen, die zwischengeschaltet werden und dadurch verlieren die eigentlichen Planer den Überblick.
Selbst wenn du schon alle Genehmigungen hast, kannst du während des Baus nochmal gestoppt werden,
weil ein Lurch, 10 Meter, von dem Schotterweg für die LKWs...
Oh ja, na das verstehe ich.
Wenn der seltene, keine Ahnung, Grünkern-Schnellkäfer da brütet,
dann muss man das natürlich absagen, verstehe ich.
Selbst wenn wir Bodenproben nehmen, müssen mindestens zwei Geologen dabei sein,
obwohl die eigentlich genau das gleiche machen.
Zu viele Regularien von der riskigen Interessens.
Okay, tja.
Das heißt, du sagst quasi, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe,
Du sagst, es ist so übertrieben bürokratisch, dass quasi die Leute mehr darauf konzentriert sind, die bürokratischen Bestimmungen einzuhalten, als realistisch auf die Gegebenheiten vor Ort zu achten.
So, um das mal so zu umschreiben.
Ja, das deckt sich auch mit vielen Beiträgen, die ich so gelesen habe, so über sinnvolle Sachen, die gebaut wurden oder nicht gebaut wurden oder gemacht wurden und dann wieder abgebaut werden.
mussten muss einzig und allein darum ging dass sich stur an irgendwelche
vorgaben gehalten wurde auch wenn ganz ersichtlich ist dass das in diesem fall
nicht passt oder umgedreht wo sich nicht stur an sinnvoll und unsinnige vorgaben
gehalten wurde und danach ein strich durch die rechnung gemacht wo ich habe
letztens einen beitrag gesehen da ging es um eine kaputten der brücke für
fahrradfahrer und die fahrradfahrer mussten quasi über ich glaube über zwei
stark befahrene straßen drüber auf die anderen seite und dann wieder zurück
damit die damit die quasi den den weg fahren konnten den sie fahren müssen das
war ein riesen umweg hat viel länger gedauert weil die brücke kaputt war und
dann hat der bürgermeister dieses ortes gesagt wisst ihr was wir legen da
einfach ein paar metall mit metall planen drüber und machen das fest und da
können die leute drüber fahren und zwar wurde hat wunderbar geklappt und dann
kam dann die, was weiß ich, die Oberlandesbaubehörde oder wer auch immer dafür zuständig ist,
hat gesagt, nee, nee, das geht so nicht.
Leute, ich hab vergessen, warum es nicht ging, aber auch wegen irgendwelchen formalen Sachen.
Und jetzt ist es halt so, die haben das abgesperrt, damit war ihre Verpflichtung getan
und was die Leute, die da drüber wollten, gemacht haben,
die haben einfach die Absperrung zur Seite geschoben und da hat es kein Sauer mehr interessiert.
Das haben wir hier auch oft, ja. Hier gibt es so eine Ecke, hier um die Ecke ist nicht allzu weit weg, gibt es so einen Park und manchmal ist da aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe, ist der hintere Zugang zu dem Park abgesperrt mit so einem Absperrband.
Ich weiß nicht warum, vielleicht machen die da irgendwelche gefährlichen Rasenmäheaktionen mit Dingern,
wenn da einer Gassi geht, gerät der Hund in den Rasenmäher oder so, keine Ahnung, zumindest wird da abgesperrt.
Witzigerweise, der Eingang vorne ist offen, ja, also du kannst da theoretisch schon rein.
Und ich hab noch nie gecheckt, also wirklich null gecheckt, noch nie gecheckt, warum das abgesperrt ist.
Was aber halt passiert ist, es ist abgesperrt, die Leute gehen da hin, sehen, ja ist nix und gehen unter der Absperrung durch.
Und nach einer Woche ist die Absperrung durchgerissen, weil irgendjemand gesagt hat, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß.
Ist das das?
Nee, den mein ich nicht.
Den Beitrag meine ich nicht, aber sowas ähnliches wird es sein.
Ja, ich bin auch der Meinung, wir haben zu viele Regularien und zu viel Bürokratie.
Das war ja mal unsere Stärke in der Vergangenheit.
Wir sind ja schon immer dafür bekannt, dass wir enorm viel Bürokratie und Regularien und alles haben.
Aber es war zumindest, hatte ich den Eindruck,
In der Vergangenheit war das eher so, ja es gibt Richtlinien, aber der jeweilige Bearbeiter hatte da schon einen gewissen Entscheidungsspielraum, um es eben der Realität anzupassen.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, mittlerweile geht es einfach nur noch stur nach Text.
Deswegen waren wir ja innovativ, halbwegs schnell und trotzdem halt sehr ordentlich und qualitativ hochwertig.
Das Problem ist, dass es bei vielen Leuten stimmt.
Aber die müssen dann halt nicht in high IQ Berufen arbeiten, ja.
Hm.
Oh je, wenn das Twitter wieder gelesen hätte.
Der Max will nicht, dass dumme Leute in anspruchsvollen Berufen arbeiten.
Da.
Oh mein Gott.
Leute, ich drehe durch.
Rage.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit
Wenn ich so recht drüber nachdenke
Dass dumme Leute
In anspruchsvollen Berufen arbeiten
Solange sie die Anforderungen dafür erfüllen
Vollkommen fein
Ja
Es muss halt irgendwie ein Filter geben
Wenn die die Ausbildung dazu schaffen
Meinetwegen, ist doch okay
Oh nein
Den Typ hatten wir auch schon, ja
Ist doch in Ordnung.
Es kann aber halt nicht jeder alles machen.
Es liegt halt nicht jedem alles.
Und die meisten Leute, die ein persönliches Interesse haben und sich für was interessieren,
die können das ja auch, weil die inneren Antrieb haben.
Aber wenn ich mir das angucke, dass eine Zeit lang im Arbeitsamt, bei so Arbeitsamtkursen,
es gang und gäbe war, irgendwie Günther, 65, kurz vor der Rente, der jetzt nicht mehr gebraucht wird im Stahlwerk, umzuschulen auf Fachinformatiker.
Einer muss mal, das liegt ja nicht, da war ja dumm, dumm war vielleicht das falsche Ausdruck, halt einfach nicht geeignet, ja, in dem Beruf.
Das ist, das kann es nicht sein, ja.
Dass da nichts Gescheites rauskommt, außer dass man in der Statistik ein Häkchen machen kann,
muss man sich ja nicht wundern.
So, was haben wir denn noch? Können wir noch irgendwas gucken?
Studium neben Job Burnout, warum viele junge Menschen am Limit sind.
Sind die das?
Sind die am Limit?
Ich habe eher den Eindruck, die meisten jungen Menschen sind viel schlauer als die älteren Menschen.
weil
ich höre immer
also ich höre häufiger
von jüngeren Menschen
dass sie keinen Bock haben auf
100% 24-7 Karriere
und alles zu machen einfach nur weil es der Chef
gesagt hat
viele junge Menschen denken direkt drüber nach
nach der Ausbildung Teilzeit und
ich lebe ja nicht nur für einen Beruf und sowas
das finde ich viel schlauer
als die Älteren
Groß Langheim bei Kitzingen.
Hier liegen noch die...
Hä? Hatten wir das nicht gerade schon?
Was ist das denn?
Da kann kein Zug mehr fahren.
Illegaler Bahnübergang spaltet Kommune.
Oh ne, das ist auch wieder...
Da reg ich mich auch wieder auf, wenn ich das...
Was können wir gucken?
Irgendwie fehlen mir Videos,
auf die ich Bock habe, die zu gucken.
Was hat denn Morpheus am Start? Hat doch jemand gesagt. Aber die sind halt so lang immer. Und wenn ich da auf ein Morpheus-Video reacte, dann brauche ich eineinhalb Stunden für das. Das ist zu lang. Was haben wir denn hier? Warum Singularität nichts als Marketing ist? Oh ne, auf KI habe ich keinen Bock. AI, AI.
Deutschland ist jetzt Überwachungsstaat.
Tja, die Zeichen
haben sich ja schon die letzten
Jahre,
wenn nicht Jahrzehnte, immer gemäht.
Und ich glaube, seit der Chatkontrolle,
seitdem die Chatkontrolle da letztens
mit wirklich
abenteuerlichem Verfahren
verabschiedet wurde, hat da kein Zweifel,
hat da, glaube ich, keiner, der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist,
Zweifel dran, dass das das Ziel ist.
Ein Schritt weiter weg von Google
Ey, das sind U-Creamers
Das kenne ich
Das steht bei mir um die Ecke
Ja, hört ihr das?
Das ist es, Chat hier, ja
Da steht's
Genau das
Oh, volls Schwanz.
Warte.
Warte, ein Fischschwarz am Start.
Mobilfunkzüberwachung ist doch schon mal ein Anfang.
Ja, was?
Woran erkennt ihr echte Texte?
Also,
KI-Texte, also,
die Standard, ohne irgendwie
großartigen Prompt.
Die Standardantworten haben wir ja schon oft im Stream
gesehen. ChatGPT schreibt
gerne. Classic.
Ah, also wenn du
Chat-GPT fragst, sag mal,
warum geht, warum geht,
ähm, keine Ahnung, Boot,
Boot, der Eintrag im
Boot-Manager bei Proxmox nicht?
Sagt er, ah, das klassische
Problem mit Proxmox und dem
Boot-Manager. Und sowas kommt dann
bei Chat-GPT immer raus.
Dies ist ein bekanntes Problem.
Also, das ist immer so
dieses Standardgelaber, Alter.
Sichere
deklarative
Secrets with Secret Spec.
Das kenn ich nicht.
Das können wir uns angucken.
Übrigens, ich hab letztens mal
Just for Fun
Chat-GPT komplett durcheinander gebracht.
Und
da hab ich mir gedacht,
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel, um Halluzinationen zu zeigen und quasi wie KI trotzdem so tut.
Als wäre das halt legit, was es sagt.
Also ich habe letztens mal gefragt, also das ist halt ein Thema, weil ich das Spiel schon lange spiele.
Ich habe letztens Chat-GPT mal schatzverfahren gefragt.
Ich, was ist die beste Speck für einen Healer auf Dark Eden?
Komplett sinnlos.
Kann ChatGPT nicht wissen.
Also ChatGPT können sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Und das ist wirklich ultra krasses Halluzin.
Oh nein, es ist tatsächlich besser geworden.
Das kann man theoretisch skillen.
Das kann man auch skillen.
Hey, das ist besser geworden.
Es hat trainiert.
Es ist krass, wie sehr diese Dinger besser werden.
Ich glaube, ich habe damals noch ein Model gefragt, was nicht im Internet nachgeguckt hat.
Also das kann man tatsächlich specken.
Und das ist sogar gar nicht verkehrt.
Das ist sogar eine ganz gute Spec.
Warum ist die beste Spec?
Ey, das ist halt schon wieder Blödsinn.
Das ist halt schon wieder teilweise Blödsinn.
Das ist...
Aber es ist krass, wie gut diese Dinger werden mit der Zeit.
Wie lange ist das her?
Weiß ich nicht, zwei Monate?
Der hat sich komplett Mist zusammen...
Ich glaube, der hat einfach nicht im Internet nachgeguckt.
Der hat sich wirklich komplett Mist aus den Fingern gesaugt zu der Spec.
Und hat das halt so geschrieben, als wüsste er voll Bescheid.
Was ist mit LinkedIn?
Was?
Was war das?
Achso.
Dieses ganze dünne Sklaven.
Ja, aber LinkedIn
ist wirklich...
Also LinkedIn war schon vor KI
Bullshit-Bingo-Extrem.
Und mit KI ist es noch schlimmer.
Auf LinkedIn gibt es
dann gibt es dann solche texte so zehn tipps zur selbstoptimierung oder sowas und dann dann ist
das zehn punkte wo wo den typ am besten noch generiert von irgendeinem model zehn punkte
wo er sich übertrieben selbst feiert so nach dem motto seit ich mich im boxingclub angenommen habe
bin ich wirklich viel durchsetzungsfähiger das nächste seitdem ich angefangen habe drei ultra
Marathons am Tag zu laufen.
Habe ich viel mehr Ausdauer und so.
Ey, Alter.
Diese Dinger kannst du komplett...
Ja, Moment.
Wie ich zwei Wochen im Urlaub
war, das habe ich daraus gelernt.
Und dann kommt...
Wisst ihr? Okay, okay. Wisst ihr was?
LinkedIn. LinkedIn.
Ich war zwei Wochen im Urlaub, das habe ich daraus gelernt.
Erster Punkt. Erster Punkt.
Sei ein Teamplayer.
Schaue auch im Urlaub morgens
direkt auf das Handy und checke deine Mails
von der Firma und helfe Kollegen, falls du kannst.
Das ist der erste Punkt.
Das ist der erste Punkt bei diesem Artikel dann.
Das ist so ein typischer LinkedIn-Artikel.
Zweiter Punkt.
Ich war in Ägypten im Urlaub
und hab da
war da Kamel reiten.
Und was mir
was mir Kamelreiten über unsere Sure-Fix-Termine beigebracht hat.
Und so ein Zeug.
Das ist wirklich echt ganz super cringe,
was da auf LinkedIn gepostet wird.
Was aber komplett out ist, ist Xing, oder?
Xing war ja eh nur in Deutschland angesagt,
aber Xing ist, glaube ich, komplett dead.
Niemand macht mehr irgendwas auf Xing.
Wann habt ihr zuletzt mal jemanden mit einem Xing Profil?
Xing ist dead, ne?
Wem gehört ein Xing eigentlich?
Wurden die nicht auch gekauft von irgendjemand letztens?
Ne
Also Xing ist dead
LinkedIn ist das
Aber LinkedIn ist echt
Also
Ich hab kein LinkedIn Account
Ich hab auch kein
irgendwie Hang dazu, mir ein Ding in den Account zu machen.
Das Einzige, was ich habe, ist, ich habe einen Fake-Account,
den ich mal angelegt habe, um ein paar lustige Sachen in einem Video zu zeigen.
Aber für den habe ich noch nicht mal mehr das Passwort.
Hier.
Den Account gibt es witzigerweise immer...
Oh, ne.
Wurde der gebannt mit? Da ist er doch.
Ja.
Das ist mein Fake-Account.
Aber ich habe leider den Zugang nicht mehr dazu.
Der ist Cloud-Native, Agile, GitHub-Solution, Chief Engineer Officer.
Warum gibt es 9 Profile?
Fuck, warum gibt es da so viele?
Okay, Chad, was wollen wir uns angucken?
Das hier, ne?
Lohnt sich das? Ist das was?
Okay, gucken wir uns das an.
Wenn der Chad sagt, das taugt was,
dann gucken wir uns das an.
Ich muss erstmal kurz den Sound ausmachen.
Zack, also.
Secure declarative secrets with secret spec.
.env files on steroids.
Also bei Überschriften, wo irgendwas on steroids ist, bin ich immer skeptisch.
Und bei Überschriften und Thumbnails, wisst ihr, wo ich auch immer super skeptisch bin?
Wenn da steht, this changes everything.
Da kannst du eigentlich davon ausgehen, so groß ist das Ding nicht.
Hab ich geguckt? Es ist...
Eigentlich müssten diese Videos komplett mein Humor sein, aber trifft's irgendwie nicht.
If you have ever had to work with any API keys, tokens, database passwords or encryption keys,
you're most definitely familiar with...
Das sind Schwede und dann Finne, oder?
Das hört sich voll skandinavisch an, der Akzent.
...the N-Files.
A well-known concept aimed to separate your secrets from your code
by moving them into a plaintext file in a form of environment variables.
They are pretty simple, supported by practical,
habe ich nicht weitergeschaut,
particularly any languages, and that's unfortunately where the trade-offs begin.
Because the moment you introduce a .env file,
your project stops being fully self-contained.
Ja, das ist wohl wahr.
Und man sollte auch aufpassen, dass man solche Dinger nicht einfach git-committed
und dann secrets drin stehen hat.
Weil es gibt ja Leute, die denken immer noch, wenn ich auf GitHub Secrets gepusht habe und die dann per Force Push wieder überschreibe, die wären weg.
Also wer das immer noch glaubt, muss ich leider den Zahn ziehen.
Das bringt nichts.
Die sind zwar oberflächlich weg, aber sind nicht wirklich weg.
Also einmal Secrets gepusht, müsst ihr Secrets rotaten. Anders geht's nicht.
Oder eure Cloud-Rechnung wird ein bisschen ausatmen in nächster Zeit.
Ja, das fand ich auch nie so sinnvoll, das in das Repo zu legen.
Das stimmt schon.
Ja.
service like bitwarden or lustpass this would make our file completely safe to commit making
it a proper part of our project take your security since all the sensitive data is now safely stored
elsewhere make secret discovery as straightforward as it can be all while giving you the developer a
central place to monitor rotate and manage your keys with your secret store of choice
wichtig
finde ich
wenn man Anwendungen baut
also moderne Anwendungen
die man kontinuieren kann, die dann
vielleicht in Docker oder Kubernetes Cluster laufen
gehen wir vom Kubernetes Cluster aus
dass sie gescheit konfigurierbar sind
auch ohne Config Files
also jetzt ohne Config Files, die irgendwie da
angelegt werden müssen im Vorfeld oder irgendwie
reinkompiliert, Secrets und so.
Das ist nichts, die über Config,
die entweder über Environment-Variablen
oder über Config-Maps,
was letztendlich Config-Files dann sind,
konfiguriert werden können.
Ich persönlich bevorzuge das Konfigurieren
über Environment-Variablen.
Das ist mir am liebsten. Ich mag Software,
die du über Environment-Variablen
konfigurieren kannst.
das nicht nur unsere Geheimnisse aus unserem Code auskoppelt,
sondern mehr wichtig,
die Werte aus der Codebase auskoppelt.
Und diese Lösung ist ein freies und open source Projekt
namens SecretSpec,
ein einfaches CLI und SDK.
Secret Provider.
SecretSpec.dev
Okay, das klingt
irgendwie ganz cool.
Stop committing
Secrets to Git, pushing them to end file.
Secrets end up...
Ja.
Also.
Initialize
SecretSpec.toml
Secret Spell Confident.
Warte.
Das finde ich eigentlich eine echt coole Idee.
Das finde ich jetzt eine echt coole Idee.
Weil sonst neigt man schon mal dazu.
Wisst ihr, das ist zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel ganz gut.
bringt mir das was?
Chat, lass mal überlegen, ob das was bringt.
Ich hatte schon öfters im Stream,
wir haben schon öfters im Stream mal ESP32 Microcontroller gebastelt.
So.
Und eine kleine Herausforderung, die ich da hatte,
ist das WLAN-Passwort.
Ich meine, ich habe schon ein extra WLAN aufgemacht
mit einem temporären Passwort für den Stream,
aber das WLAN Passwort wollte ich ja nicht trotzdem nicht im Stream zeigen.
So, was ich dann gemacht habe ist, ich habe einen Secrets Header File angelegt
und dort quasi eine Variable angelegt, eine globale Variable,
aber auf so eine Art und Weise, dass Autocomplete nicht den Inhalt anzeigt
und die habe ich dann immer eingebunden.
Hat natürlich trotzdem immer das Risiko geborgen, da drauf zu klicken.
Würde das hierfür irgendwas bringen überhaupt?
Weil das WLAN-Passwort muss ja statisch in die Firmware reinkompiliert werden, damit das funktioniert.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte während dem Build-Vorgang einen Step, der meine Secret-Spec abfragt oder sowas macht.
Da müsste man irgendein Build-Skript bauen, was das quasi abfragt und dann irgendwie mit einem Search and Replace oder so.
Würde vielleicht was helfen, ja.
Aber wir gucken uns das jetzt trotzdem erstmal an.
Initialize Secret Spec.
Ja, haben wir schon.
Init from Env.
Wannet.
So.
Tommel.
Tommel ist voll angesagt bei den ganzen Rust-Lore.
Lass mich raten, das ist written in Rust.
Ja, natürlich.
Was sonst?
C-Sharp?
Was ist da von C-Sharp?
Ah, für .NET.
Für .NET.
Für .NET Secrets wahrscheinlich.
Secrets back .NET.
Hallo, GitLab.
Please, öffnen.
Alter, GitLab.
Ah, da kann man direkt aus der Anwendung drauf zugreifen.
Gut, bringt mir auf dem ESP32 nichts.
So, da steht dann so Sachen drin wie Profiles, Default, Redis-URL, Required, was?
profiles development profiles des productions aber wo stellt man jetzt ein
wo das herkommt sehr ahrs der provider becker da kann ich sagen aus dem kieper
Ja, eigentlich richtig cool.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit einen Keypass für unser Team.
Da sind hunderte Passwörter drin.
So, manchmal brauche ich da Passwörter, um Dinge zu erledigen, Command-Line-technisch.
Das könnte ich ja quasi auch so als Art
Roman-Klein-Key-Pass verwenden oder so.
Das finde ich ist ein cooles Projekt.
Was ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz gecheckt habe, ist
die Verbindung von den Secrets
zu dem Backend.
Ah, Secret Spec Set Database.
Ach, verstehe, verstehe, okay.
Okay.
Das ist eigentlich ein richtig cooles Projekt.
Ja, irgendwie sowas müsste ich dann bauen.
Ich brauche auf jeden Fall irgendeine Custom Build Step.
Ich finde das Projekt richtig nice.
Wisst ihr was, das werden wir mal ausprobieren.
Da machen wir jetzt keinen extra Stream für.
Aber.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist. Brauchen wir nicht.
Zack.
Das probiere ich mal aus.
Die nächsten Streams über.
Wenn wir wieder Secrets brauchen.
Klingt mir nach einem sehr sinnigen Projekt.
Oder was sagt ihr? Findet's klingt nicht schlecht.
Dann müssen wir uns das Video jetzt nicht angucken.
Wir gucken uns das Video im Schnelldurchgang an.
Natürlich nix, Enjoyer.
1,2 ist beste.
Okay, also was machst du jetzt? Du legst das an, dann sagst du Secret Set Provider Keyring My Secret Password nach Frage.
Ah ja, dann hinterlegt er das auch. Oder musst du das vorher da drin eintragen?
Und mehr wichtig, run any commands with their secrets present as environment variables with the secretspec run –yourcommand.
Ja gut, aber wie kann ich die Secrets jetzt zu Environment-Variablen setzen?
You can see, aside from including the secretspec file, we don't have to modify any project logic at all.
This makes secretspec files...
Weil get ist ja schön und gut, aber ob, wo willst du die als Environment-Variablen setzen?
...
Ich finde aber cool, dass es da ein SDK für nahezu alle Programmiersprachen gibt.
Das heißt, du kannst das quasi so als Bridge verwenden von Programmiersprache X zu Passwort Store Y.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Was supportet das für Provider?
Ja, Keyring, Keypass, Env, Plaintext, OnePass, OneLancer, Dashline, Pass.
Okay, pw-save, was wir früher auf der Arbeit benutzt haben, nicht.
Was aber auch okay ist, outdated, overrated, jebaited, alte Software.
Hey, das ist ja eigentlich noch...
Hey, das ist ja richtig cool.
Wenn man da Default-Sachen angeben kann, dann kann man dieses...
dann kann man das, hey, das ist gar nicht schlecht,
wenn du Default-Werte angeben kannst,
dann kannst du dieses Secrets-Back-File
einchecken in dein Repo
und für einen lokalen
Dev-Run oder so,
nimmst du dann die Default-Secrets
und für alles
weitere, wenn du das brauchst,
die aus deinem Secret-Manager.
Und
Das Ding ist nur, das einzige, was ich mich jetzt frage noch ist, wenn du das Secrets Manager SDK verwendest, weil, kann das Kubernetes Secrets verwenden?
Das wäre nämlich enormst pock.
Kann es das?
Kann es nicht, oder?
Nee, kann es nicht.
Macht ja auch keinen Sinn, weil die Anwendung da drinnen kann ja nicht auf die Secrets zugreifen.
Die Secrets müssen ja gemountet werden.
Ja, wie machst du das jetzt?
Wie würdest du dann, also ich gette das Ding, aber wie würdest du dann im produktiven Betrieb die Passwörter in die Anwendung bekommen?
Weil du verwendest, sagen wir mal hier, okay, machen wir das mal exemplarisch so.
Du verwendest, ja, aber gegen API-Server.
Du willst jetzt ja nicht unbedingt, dass dein produktiver Kubernetes-Cluster
irgendwie Zugang hat zu deinem Passwort-Save direkt.
Dafür gibt es ja Secrets.
Ja, Kubernetes-Secrets sind ja nicht wirklich Secret, das ist nach wie vor Plaintext, aber der Weg eigentlich, wie man das konfiguriert.
Also man bräuchte, man bräuchte, nee, Kubernetes-Secrets sind nicht safe, aber es ist in der Regel auch nicht so das Problem, weil auf dieser Ebene haben eh nur Google-Admins oder Cloud-Admins oder Kubernetes-Admins Zugriff.
Ja, das ist nicht so, aber es ist das, was hauptsächlich benutzt wird. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier, sagen wir ich benutze secretspec.net, so, dann kann ich das machen, aber ich bräuchte noch, naja, Moment, nee, das ist doch ganz einfach.
Es ist doch eigentlich ganz einfach.
Der Fallback, man kann doch da bestimmt einen Fallback einstellen, oder?
With Provider, mit Provider, kann man mehrere Provider einstellen?
Genau, genau das habe ich mir nämlich auch gedacht hier, Suffades.
Wenn man einen Fallback einstellen kann, oder wenn man sagen könnte,
In Produktion möchte ich doch Env-Files verwenden.
Zur Laufzeit injecten ist der Play.
Naja, ganz ehrlich, das finde ich sehr hakelig.
Ich kenne das, es gibt Software.
Das ist quasi so ein Passwort-Manager im Endeffekt.
der wiederum, also du startest eigentlich den Passwortmanager in deinem Pod, der Passwortmanager wiederum holt sich die Credentials ab und der Passwortmanager startet dann deinen eigentlichen Prozess und injectet dort per Environment oder Parameter dein Passwort.
Ja, das ist theoretisch ein bisschen sicherer.
Admins können das ganze Ding natürlich trotzdem hijacken.
Aber macht es super kompliziert.
Also bin ich jetzt kein Fan von Laufzeit-Injecten.
Aber gehen tut das, ja, macht es ein bisschen sicherer.
Laufzeit-Injecten, das könntest du im Endeffekt hiermit ja machen.
Da würdest du dich verbinden.
Aber dann braucht halt der Anwendungspot...
Zugriff auf deinen Passwort-Manager.
Da bin ich jetzt nicht so.
Aber was natürlich gehen würde, ist, wenn du sagst,
with provider keyring, with provider endfile,
und er nimmt einfach das, was da ist.
In Production ist es halt einfach endfile.
Und dann mountest du dir deine Secrets als Endpfeil rein und es geht.
Also das, okay, es gibt Möglichkeiten.
Vom Ansatz her finde ich die Idee hier aber ziemlich gut.
Ja, an sich finde ich das hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Und jetzt, dass wir verstehen, wie ein Geheimdienst funktioniert, schauen wir uns ein paar
seiner anderen Features an, die es noch cooler machen.
Das erste und wichtigste ist natürlich seine Gartner.
Weil nachdem das Geheimdienst-File ausgeschlossen ist, lässt es nicht das Projekt laufen, bis
du die gebrauchten Geheimdienste gesetzt hast und lässt nicht, dass du Geheimdienste, die
nicht definiert wurden, gesetzt hast.
Nicht aus Sicherheitsgründen, sondern nur aus Gewissheit.
Denke an Datatypen in stark getypten Sprachen.
Sie sind technisch nicht nötig, du kannst ein wenig Zeit dafür verbringen, sie zu schreiben,
writing them but in the long run they just make your life easier and with the convenient profiles
feature you can also define different rules or secrets should follow depending on the profile
like in this example where our api key value will be required in the default profile but come with
some default testing value in the development profile deployed program will refuse to run
until we set our keys but during development we will have some internal default value
but i already hear you say
na ja gut wenn ich mir jetzt noch mal recht überlege wenn ich mir dieses beispiel hier angucke
man könnte ja
man könnte ja einfach
bei der App
eben Stage
setzen, ja, dass man dann quasi sagt
wenn Stage
explizit auf Testing gesetzt ist
dann nimmt er Keyring und wenn es auf
Production gesetzt ist, nimmt er Endfile
was dann über Secrets gemountet wird
also das wird
schon funktionieren
eigentlich kein Problem
Doch, da muss halt die Anwendung so gestrickt sein.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, ob ich es komplett feiere.
Vom Ansatz her finde ich es aber gut.
und wenn wir jetzt da mal von ausgehen, dass es hauptsächlich
eben um
Testing und Development Sachen
geht
und nicht um Production
Betrieb
also quasi so, Entwickler kann sich das Ding
auschecken, lokal starten und
da ein paar Tests mitmachen
dafür ist es sinnvoll
für in Produktion
die Secrets bereitstellen, das würde ich weiter über
ein Kubernetes Configment bzw. ein Kubernetes
Secret machen, was dann da
reingemountet wird und
per Environment Variable oder per
ILE zur Verfügung
gestellt wird. Da würde ich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal dieses
wahrscheinlich würde ich gar nicht dieses SDK
überhaupt benutzen.
Sondern das einfach in
Environment Variablen direkt
umformen lassen, sodass ich
immer den gleichen Weg benutzen kann, auch im
Das ist doch eigentlich gar keine schlechte Idee, oder? Man benutzt Secret Spec, um Environment Variablen zu populaten und in seinem Programm nimmt man zum Konfigurieren einfach immer Environment Variablen. Dann kann man das in Production nehmen, in Test, aber für Test und Int und sowas nimmt man halt Secret Spec, um seine Environment Variablen zu setzen.
Das klingt doch nach einem guten Kompromiss, dass man SecretSpec im Endeffekt als universellen Passwortmanager verwendet.
Und im Falle von Rust lässt es dich sogar mit einem Makro nutzen, um
Secret-Strucks im Compile-Zeit zu generieren, um die Sekret-Typen sicher zu machen.
Oder du mountest ein Endfile rein.
Ich glaube, da gibt es keinen Standardweg für Docker selbst.
Okay, für Secrets benutze ich immer das hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine High-IQ-Geschichte ist, ob das das Beste ist oder nicht.
Ich benutze immer pwgen.
Das sind Passwörter, die man tippen kann.
Die enthalten nicht 30 Milliarden Sonderzeichen oder so.
Und pwgen ist halt super simpel.
Pass auf, das ist bestimmt ein Perl-Programm.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Ne, ist es nicht.
Ist es nicht.
pwgen github
generate
pronounceable passwords
na ob die so wirklich pronounceable sind
bin ich mich nicht so sicher, wie soll man das aussprechen
ok3eint
7po7rei
naja
ein vault agent, ja das ist auch
ein Ding
könnte man auch benutzen
anstatt Secret Spec.
Ich finde die Idee
aber definitiv ganz sinnvoll.
Moment, pwgen?
Wie alt ist das?
15 Jahre?
Moment,
wie alt ist das Programm, was ich...
Alter!
Benutze ich in 15 Jahren als Programm, um Passwörter zu generieren?
Ja, wirklich?
Alter, fuck!
Gibt's hier irgendwie...
Theodore TS.
Okay.
Okay, shit, Alter.
15 Jahre, Alter.
Oh, no.
Ich hoffe, das ist secure.
Nicht wie dieser komische...
...Hardware-Token.
Ja.
Müssen wir doch mal gucken.
Müssen wir doch gleich mal checken, wie das Passwort da generiert,
ob ich da truste.
Truste ich da Sachen?
pwgen c, okay.
Das ist alles egal.
Alles egal.
Wo wird das pwgen?
Ähm.
pwrent?
pwappas?
Hier wird das doch generiert, oder?
Ne
Wo wird denn hier das Passwort letztendlich generiert?
Rusty-Write, ja
Sind
Buff
PW-Gen
Da ist es
Include pwgen.h
äh, pwgen.h
wo kommt denn jetzt hier die Funktion pwgen her?
pwgen
was ist denn die mempage, oder?
ähm, ich bin zu dumm hier diesen c-code zu lesen
guck mal, der ruft pwgen auf, aber das wird nirgends wo
das wird nirgendwo definiert? Wo kommt denn das her?
Aus der
Header-Datei? Da habe ich doch gerade gesucht. Da kam es nicht her.
Hier.
Da kommt es her, oder?
pwgen
char buff
Hier. pwgen
gleich
Oder nicht?
PW Phone Names
Da kommt es her
Hier, hier kommt der
Gen-Generator
Und wo kommt hier die Randomness her?
Ne
Alter, ich bin...
Ich check's nicht.
Okay.
Wisst ihr was?
Where is the
PV generation?
How does
PV gen work?
Oh, bam.
Äh, das ist...
Okay, das war eine dumme Frage.
How does it generate randomness?
The keyboard itself doesn't invent randomness.
It's asking the operating system for...
Okay, opens you random.
Okay, ich verlasse mich drauf.
Das ist random genug.
Show me the code where it uses uRandom.
Randnam, okay.
Okay, okay.
Randnam, das gibt's doch überhaupt nicht.
Doch, Randnam.c tatsächlich.
Fuck, Chat gibt dir ja recht, okay.
Okay, dann ist das safe.
würde ich sagen,
wenn es URandom verwendet,
Time of Day, das ist immer
ein bisschen problematisch.
Guck mal, das basiert
auch auf
Time of Day.
Da kann man sich jetzt fragen, wie random das Ganze überhaupt ist.
Ist pwgen secure?
It's really good.
Uses the random password generator and obtains randomness from UDF random.
The Linux kernel describes it.
Don't use normal.
Okay, das heißt, der Normal-Mode
suckt, oder wie?
Ach so, minus S.
Ja, ist doch auch okay.
Und die sind jetzt besser?
Gut, whatever.
Wird schon, wird schon,
wird schon passen. So oft hab ich das auch nicht.
Das hab ich meistens nur für irgendwelche
lokalen Kisten oder so.
Minus S for secure.
Ich fänd's merkwürdig, dass ein Passwortgenerator
standardmäßig nicht secure ist.
Oder nicht so secure ist.
Gut.
Okay, Leute.
Essen ist am Start. Ich muss jetzt was futtern.
3 Stunden 30.
Vielleicht machen wir heute Nachmittag.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal meine Runde Training machen.
Runde Rennen.
Achso, Chat, wenn ihr da seid, Frage.
Was soll ich heute machen?
Ihr müsst mich mal kurz beraten.
Gestern hatte ich 1 Stunde 12 Long Run.
Gestern bin ich...
Moment, ich kann es euch sagen.
Also ich merke es heute auch noch ein bisschen in den Beinen.
Gestern bin ich...
Ich glaube, also ich bin eine Stunde zwölf gerannt gestern.
Entspannt, 6,19er Pace im Durchschnitt.
Eine Stunde zwölf, 145 Puls, 11,42 Kilometer.
So, das habe ich gestern gemacht.
Warum PepoFett nicht mehr animiert ist, gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt habe ich ein paar Sachen zur Auswahl.
Und zwar, ich habe einen super langweiligen 6,30er Pace 42 Minuten Bass Run. Da habe ich aber ehrlich gesagt wenig Bock drauf, heute nochmal 42 Minuten Bass langsam rumzulaufen.
Alternativ könnte ich ein VO2 Max Run machen. Das sind 4x4 Minuten at 5er Pace und dann 15 Minuten einlaufen, 10 Minuten auslaufen, insgesamt 42 Minuten. Also 4x4 Minuten 5er Pace, das ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich anstrengend.
Oder ich hätte noch zur Auswahl ein
Anerobic Run
7x1 Minute
At 4,35er Pace
Das ist auch anstrengend
Also 4,35er Pace kann ich über vielleicht 1, wenn ich es voll wissen will, 2 Kilometer rennen
Das war's
So, Vorschläge, was ich davon machen soll von den 3
Es ist sau warm wieder, wirklich
Och nee, hab ich keinen Bock drauf, warte mal, lass mich mal kurz
Gucken, wie viel Grad haben wir hier
Home Assistant, fuck
34,4 Grad
Ich glaube, da mach ich heute weder das noch das andere
Da mach ich heute wirklich den
Den langsamen
Den langsamen Max mach ich heute
Ja.
Ne.
Stopp.
Hm.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich,
siebenmal eine Minute,
4,35, ne?
Das ist wenigstens schnell vorbei.
Leak.
Fuck.
Das ist wenigstens schnell vorbei
Ich glaube
Ich glaube 7x1 Minute schnell rennen
Ist in der Hitze angenehmer
Als 42 Minuten
Entspannt
Weil es ist schneller wieder durch
Naja mal gucken
Mal gucken was ich mach
Also, wenn ich das noch hinkriege, dann streamen wir heute Abend wahrscheinlich noch eine Runde Python-Command-Line-Anwendungen, CLI-Anwendungen und machen hier den Python-Lernen, Max.
Also vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Abend. Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat, wenn ihr solche Streams mögt,
könnt ihr mir auch ein Follow da lassen.
An der Stelle freut mich immer. Grüne Pfeile, die nach oben zeigen
in irgendwelchen Statistiken,
sind immer sehr motivierend.
Also einfach einmal
folgen. Da freue ich mich drüber.
Und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.